[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
sir
my check
might check
how my levels sounding what's going on
around sunday
it's the lord's day it's that day
be back
what's going on
talk to me
four guys recorders what's going on i
see you it's that clowns i see you imax
what's going on i see you gerald mack
always first or hell the iop salute
gen x 128 what's up what's going on you
already know appreciate you christopher
heart okay salute to the impeachment you
know salute to you the dusty one no
doubt happy sunday no doubt no doubt
let's talk to him we got a big one you
know what i'm saying we got a big one
xbox loyalty in the building microsoft
royalty the building cloud streaming in
the building but we've got lord added to
that show as well might check sir
what's going on guys
see what's up man oh what is this atomic
atomic sands what's going on
why you got knees you got you got cats
and boxes all right cats in the box
alice the eight what's going on talk to
me what's the word what's the word my
dna dna too
what's good round what's the word what's
the word okay
[Music]
before havoc what's the word what's the
word
shout out to dna too
you'll be killing me with that
anyway we're gonna have a good show
today got a lot of fun topics you know
what i'm saying hopefully he gets off
for a little bit you know he's got a lot
of stuff going on i hate what i say
you know he said love to solve when he
has stuff going on but i'll still say
send love to saul
he may pop through we'll see what's
going on but um you know the king pull
it up and yeah it's gonna be lit lydia
master man what's going on wait naive
that's fleur wait hold on that's big
it's big flurb home
is that fleur from the bx
it was going no i know that name you
already know what's up brody oh he flerv
is home good to see you brother good
good that you're doing all right we will
definitely chop it up i think i missed
your call i think i know what happened
last week okay we're gonna chop it up
you already know anyway
for havoc what's going on you know what
i'm saying we got some bronze love in
the building i see you you know what i'm
saying but um yeah we're gonna get the
show popping we got xbox executives in
the building we're gonna have a fun show
what are they gonna be so you know what
i'm saying they're gonna get pillows
but anyway look
shout out to my man nain you know i'm
saying that's big flirt you know what
i'm saying he's home now that's good to
see but anyway yo we're gonna get this
show popping i will be back
and we'll have a fun one
[Music]
welcome to the show if you would not
mind go ahead and uh find yourself a
spot get comfortable grab a snack do all
that good stuff that we need to do and
um you know we're about to get started i
am well it's not important who i am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron lords podcast right now
as we speak and uh i guess i'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so um
turn me to an animal and haters be
swearing they real but come to find out
that they really mechanical and yeah i
be eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't want to be
on a song with me that's understandable
i kill a beat and they wanna compare me
to freddie and jason i'd rather be
hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all so
dramatical i know it's random but i am
addicted to flipping the sample and
making it flammable this is that
this is
love my city but i'm still about coastal
[Music]
look i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled for them to be your dog thing
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't here to boil you you ain't gotta
say it i'm embarrassed for you i've
always been a nerd never been a loser
making voltron with a gang of cougars
and i'm going places better tell her
uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
freddy krueger
let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people on
aim
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making voltron with
the gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing they
real but coming to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't want to be
on a song with me that's understandable
i kill a beat and they want to compare
me to freddie and jason i'd rather be
hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all so
dramatical i know it's random
when i'm in the range i was the hardest
to start regardless back we was
[Music]
look i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled for them to be your dog thing
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't here to boy you ain't gotta say it
i'm embarrassed for you i've always been
a nerd never been a loser making voltron
with a gang of cougars and i'm going
places better tell her uber cause it's
pretty hard to sleep on freddy krueger
that's
who let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
[Music]
but that's all a part of me being
accountable and they say i'm better than
money because you can bank on me being
accountable i know a million rappers
that don't want to be on a song with me
that's understandable i kill a beat and
they want to compare me to freddie and
jason i'd rather be hannibal they'd be
like why use a video game just be
original y'all so dramatical i know it's
random but i'm addicted to flipping the
sample and making it flammable this is
that
fire this is the yoga playing they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back with messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city
[Music]
you ain't gotta say it i'm embarrassed
for you i always been a nerd never been
a loser making voltron with a gang of
cougars and i'm going places better tell
her uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep
on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lord's podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all have missed up and turned me
to an animal and headless be swearing
that real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't want to be
on a song with me that's understandable
i kill a beat and they want to compare
me to freddie and jason i'd rather be
hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all so
dramatical i know it's random but i'm
addicted to flipping the sample and
making it flammable this is that
this is that yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting
um
[Music]
but i ain't gonna hold you i ain't here
to boy you ain't gotta say it i'm
embarrassed for you i always been a nerd
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look you gotta mess up and turn me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted
when i'm in the range i was the hardest
to start regardless back we were
messaging people
[Music]
you could say that i'm very spoiled for
them to be your dog thing very loyal but
i ain't gonna hold you i ain't here to
boy you ain't gotta say it i'm
embarrassed for you always been a nerd
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
[Music]
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on the
song with me that's understandable i
kill a beat and they wanna compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i am addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by
[Music]
say it i'm embarrassed for you always
been a nerd never been a loser making
voltron with a gang of cougars and i'm
going places better tell her uber cause
it's pretty hard to sleep on freddy
krueger
let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lord's podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i be eating
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on the
song with me that's understandable i
kill a beat and they want to compare me
to freddie and jason i'd rather be
hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all so
dramatical i know it's random but i'm
addicted to flipping the sample and
making it flammable this is that
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber because it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger that's
who it's down to cheating on mosey on
down over to the website go check it out
whether you're going to get that focus
for the gaming session that energy a
little perk for the gym we're going to
get some swag some merch maybe a ice
shaker go right on over there check out
the products but again really cool
products they don't hide behind any type
of proprietary blend
nonsense it's all transparent as far as
the ingredients the label green tea
caffeine kind of a healthy form of
natural caffeine none of that crash none
of that stuff so yeah again go check it
out you run in there you add it to your
cart use that referral link that we got
in the description and then you make
sure on the checkout you're putting in
iron lord again iron lord on the
checkout get yourself a nice discount
when you're checking out advanced gg and
like i said try the product for yourself
see what you think about it the lords we
love it and we are powered by advanced
gg so check that thing out
[Music]
a proclamation
[Music]
if i can imagine this cooler give you
some advice and invite your girl to your
squadron cause if you don't give her
that option you're gonna be single
player like siren you're gonna get
tossed in the bushes by king david
royalty and not a pretender detrimental
to an elemental what's an avatar to a
knee bender i gotta be me though i know
it's my destiny worked a cognito who
cares if you fly if you steal a mosquito
you swear you ain't something but really
be stevo
you like to collect stuff and that's
cool but i got bad news even if you
really watch that you can never still be
the king of the statues since the
juvenile i've been cursed with a curse
to be musical and if you hate it we'll
meet in the crucible wasn't it nothing
it's cool and it's beautiful we let you
know that your dreams are pursued but
whatever you want to do then it's doable
if you got work on a sunday and suitable
cause you can listen to this in your
cubicle on the lord's day
if you got work on a sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on a lord's day
[Music]
and we are live do a quick mic check
right quick i want to see some some
levels there there we go there we go i
see them now i just want to make sure
and welcome to the iron laws podcast llc
and also live on lordsofgaming.net
episode number 252.
and it's another glorious sunday we're
back at the round table on the lord's
day i'm extremely excited about our
special guest and we've got xbox cloud
streaming
halo infinite lone wolves and the
coalition unreal engine 5 demo to
discuss so we're going to get right into
it
i want to introduce a lord who is not
only blazing a trail in the emerging
space of console technology but has
empowered the passion as a hardcore
gamer to truly play next generation
experiences wherever we are into the
devices of our choosing
introducing microsoft's senior program
manager of game streaming product and
strategy at xbox
and the head of the enormous marvel
cinematic universe facebook page
the lord of azure and the mcu
fellow destiny brethren
who has survived every
self-proclaimed destiny killer
live from washington and kind enough to
make his debut into the realm of the
lords
my man lord lockheed aka paris lockhart
of xbox how we doing sir
oh yes yes thank you thank you for the
intro man that man can i get that at
work
what you do is like instead of insane
stream starting soon you just have that
on repeat
[Laughter]
absolute honor to have you in the realm
first of all man how you been and what
you've been playing sir what's been
going on with you oh man i've been good
man uh just uh you know work
uh
family work you know covet i'm sure
everybody's been dealing with that
everybody has been dealing with that now
that we're sort of seeing
the light break in the end of the tunnel
and everybody sort of back out there
doing almost normal stuff so it's good
it's good
um uh what i've been playing man i just
i just booted up eldon ring so
um uh you know i beat it i i played
witch queen ran through that
i had some fun with that but i still got
some missions to do i still got some uh
some exotics who are quiet yeah yes the
witch queen so i still gotta go
yeah
yeah i do too
yeah um and uh uh yeah eleanor ring oh
my gosh
talk to us talk to us yeah snatch your
soul didn't it yes
i ran through the the tutorial i was
like what is everybody talking about i
could run i
oh my god
the first dude i saw outside the
building you know i know horse i was
like man what can happen you know what's
funny he got
angry
you know what's funny paris when i
played the the actual game because i was
uh because of um
cog i was able to get into the network
test
and so i was i was playing the network
test and i already seen people posting
the tree sitting on twitter like getting
killed and i saw him quit like walking i
was like i'm gonna go laugh
i'm gonna leave that a little bit so
like how many hours i went out there i
seen some blood stains i was like
[Music]
tell me it's not dope that you see blood
stains to give you an indication of
death right yeah it's like because if i
see a lot of them i'm like wow something
crazy
i love that touch to it and the notes i
love that though
there's a tunnel that you go down
and there was nothing but blood stains i
was like yeah i'm not ready yet
there's ten thousand runes on me i'm
like i'm not going down there's a part
in the game that i don't know if any of
you guys got to it i think king has i
won't like spoil it but it's like a
giant battlefield and you're so many a
like
like ally ais over and over again like
it's like a giant it's yeah it's i won't
go say the name but
he won't know about that until he when
he when you know about that guy that i
just said when you know about him you
already know where you was at because
you're gonna get a big giant cinematic
and you're gonna be like this is not
real so
what's funny
walking through the portal and him
shooting a giant craw like a giant great
bow just shooting you over and over
again because it's pretty much about
royale you versus him versus like 50
people
it's so dope and and the best part about
it is well what we lord to do is uh well
what that lord right there down at the
bottom does
i'm sitting here like we right you know
with him
he's out with savant that helps right so
he reaches out and he goes to people
worlds
and helps them beat bosses so he has
this big shield yeah i don't know where
he got it from and i'm hunting for the
shield right yeah
he's he took a hit from a boss that
usually kills you with one shot
he took it and looked at him and laughed
i said oh you you're too strong i'd love
to do that you love this show off in
your world to the point of paris we're
like i'll be fighting people
that are just so aggressive and i i was
hoping someone and i had to show it up
and he's like yo that was gonna kill you
i'm like step aside
coming through let the real man handle
the ball
yeah he'll help us do the fringe stuff
but i salute to you parents
go for it when you when you're uh when
you summon your friends and you're all
running through and then somebody
invades you there's there's sometimes
where you can't fight that person they
got like a shield around them then
there's some times where you can all
jump in and and and stop them from
killing the main person like
what's up with that talk about that
co-op i don't know that that's probably
a spell he put a spell on himself take a
couple hits so you ought to get him to
get rid of the the the barrier and then
you can continue heading what's funny is
i'll be i'll be in things that were like
two or like two people invaded it's not
too hard to get rid of them as long as
like you have the proper equipment now
like we have a friend named blaze he's
like specializes in pcp i ain't touching
none of that i am
openly invading for the beef
that's the stuff that i like like your
parents when i saw the game and i'm
tired of taking too much from your
segment yeah i'm worried somewhere
when i saw the game and i realized that
i can jump into people's world and just
wreak havoc i said yo i can't wait for
this game this this is because i'm not a
souls dude so i said this is what it is
so when i told sovereign i said i need
this from the iron bank i need to do
this he didn't believe that i was going
to be playing this game
you can get your head smacked clean off
your body
i realized very early on my ambitions to
be an invader is definitely music
differently
about some of the people that try to
invade us they run for me but sooner or
later i get it i run in the back and i
got that potion you'll be able to get
that potion later on paris the um the
one that puts a bubble around you and
shields so you can take a couple of hits
when you're fighting the boss and it's
really good real quick shout out to the
chat they are going crazy for laura
paris xbox snowboard right now they was
like the drip is crazy the expert real
quick we got can i get some knowledge on
the snowboard part that's fine they want
to know oh oh the oh the xbox snowboard
yeah um i got that during one of our uh
uh like our give campaign things and um
that wasn't a failure got it signed by
p3 himself
i think that's two of so there's 15 of
them that's two or fifteen
and then they just did an auction not
too long ago for zero so like okay it
was a big auction and people were the
dominant and there's a bunch of charity
and stuff like that so yeah
i haven't used it yet still gives me
crap about it so
watch it wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait you snowboard
who feels yeah no you
yeah well yeah i'm working on it yeah i
have one i have one right here too it's
just one okay so what i'm gonna tell you
is just because your friend snowboard
that don't mean you guys
i wouldn't know on the fact that if
you're gonna do it see the skin
like that but the
skateboard sensibilities in my opinion
yeah it's got skateboard it's like
almost like skateboard law yeah no no no
exactly
exactly absolutely
tried to get me to go to some
snowboarding thing i said no
i said my idea of vacation is not me
laying up there
you
valued your safety i don't know i don't
go anywhere on vacation where there's
snow bro
like yo i'll meet you in the cabin lodge
and i'll be watching the games
you gonna do that snowboarding thing
y'all gonna do that you'll see it but i
did try i did travel like we got we got
to move on
besides that that's been predominantly
what you've been playing lord uh
lockheed
yeah
just build up elton ring and uh uh you
know destiny two all day every day you
already
already know what it is
you know we got the four horsemen of
gaming those original lords of the realm
here at the round table my co-host with
the cold mouse my brother from another
mother the difficult game conqueror lord
of his own world and the how of the
young wolf my man lord addict of the
attic show how we doing sir i'm doing
pretty good man uh before the show i
actually watched that kingdom hearts 4
trailer
so you know i actually recorded a
reaction we'll put it up for the members
in patreon so okay you guys want to see
my my blind reaction to it uh definitely
look into that you know first of all i
want to say is like there's a lot of
hate for a game none of you playing oh
yeah
there's a lot of hate for a game none of
you care about
the moment kingdom hearts comes up in
the news i feel like people just like
they get they they love it they're like
oh i could talk snap about a game i
don't care
that's all i'm gonna say
i'm gonna go back to drinking my profile
all right go do that go do that you
already know and of course we have very
happy to have him here
most technical gaming lord the solo
gamer who lives for the single player
selfish experience and also the
sastradamus the lord of clarity and lord
patron of the iron bank my man lord
sovereign on limited time but happy to
hear well he's alive people are very
limited very limited time
so
just just real quick uh shanee put a
code for eldon right yeah oh wow look at
that thank you
first of all i want to thank everyone in
the realm who who came out you know and
expressed their condolences
for me not being on the show it was a
situation we had to let them know we had
to leverage okay i mean it you know it
is a heart wrenching thing when i you
know i have to work instead of being
here you know so
condolences appreciated
but uh um yeah
i'm gonna have to break it hard again um
so i'm here i just want to let you guys
know
uh
i will not be on the show until after
pax yes um i am moving and
the thing is the exact date isn't pinned
down so it might happen right before pax
and or it might happen right after pax
so the problem with that is
the only time off that i have is the
week of packs yeah
so
the adult thing to do would be like hey
guys i can't go to pax
i'm not doing the adult thing
i appreciate it no no no no listen i got
to be on the show floor my brother's
been two years since i haven't been
there
you know king and i had we're running up
and down those aisles you know
i need my my um interview guy my my tag
team partner oh yes sir
as great as hector was
uh i'm i'm the cameraman paris and my
job i keep them on a cadence he
understands my cadence we will see every
last one of those 400 games is down on
that floor yeah you know
we'll have every game every interview
and um i love his energy and i love his
delivery so i'm so happy that he's gonna
be there with you oh yeah that's that
and then
look at me
sir and then
and then king will look at me and say yo
can you make 400 thumbnails
yeah so i would definitely not be
missing packs uh you could see our
coverage there like king said the
lawyers get down at pax so it's gonna be
a fun time so uh but i will not be on
the show until after pax so uh i just
want to say apologize to paris because i
really i really really want to stay but
uh and obviously to my brothers i will
see you guys in a week and a half and
everybody in the chat everybody who
follows us again thank you i appreciate
it i love y'all i will see y'all in
a couple of weeks and and my brothers
i'll see you in a week and a half real
quick the last hurrah that i had before
uh today's purge day actually so i'm
very happy because okay i like i'm a
minimalist lady sob not so much so i'm
confusing things and she's crying in the
corner that's fine um
so uh i saw sonic yesterday uh
good things good things
bro we took our nephew to see it okay it
is i heard it's the greatest it's
amazing really it really is it really
the
i've been told
the comedy the action the callbacks
everything works all of it none of it is
cringy if it's cringe it's cringy in the
way you expect for
for the property you know what i mean
and it's as somebody who's a fan of the
property who's been with sonic since i
was a little kid it they just get
everything right and then clown says
knuckles is awesome knuckles is awesome
tails is all
alba is absolutely perfect that's
knuckles hip hop um gamer has a
interview interview with l yes
yes yeah he does almond and who else um
yeah tails was great and then deal with
jim carrey like this this role
is made for jim carrey two you know what
he said scenery like he's well he's
retired he said after this he said he
said that depending i think he's got one
more contract for one more sonic movie
but they said depending on how because
apparently he wants to enroll like the
bigger eggman you know what i'm saying
like the one that's really he wants to
do that it seems like if they if they
let him go that direction he might stay
for another one okay i'll tell you this
this is
again jim carrey's always been known for
chewing up scenery this is a movie where
it it's good that he chews up scenery
because he's that good as this you know
over-the-top villain and it's just
perfect it was so great
so yeah let me you want me to read these
super chats
i was go i was like if please
because we won't get the glorious
reading from you you don't say that this
because all reading is terrible i'm i'm
not holding this come on
we got forza legend ten dollar super
chat i just wanted to say good morning
lords i will say this now sonic the
hedgehog 2 movie is the greatest video
game movie ever wow it was a joy to take
my son and daughter to see it 10 out of
10. i'm not gonna lie and you know what
was great too the energy of the crowd
the kids there really really kids got
into it honestly
when knuckles came out when tales came
out when the post credit scene happened
like there were parents leaving and the
kids screaming no what are you doing
like what are you doing no the kids know
the vibes yeah they know oh yeah shout
out to marvel yeah yep
who said the president speaking of which
like real quick solving i don't know i
don't have you on your limited time um i
finally did see the baby and it was
amazing and i just wanted to let you
know you know saying that that's
detective comics
yeah that is the badass
i had to talk
he wasn't a good detective in this book
no but he was trying this is he was
learning and the was awesome
the reason that i like the sonic stuff
too much is because like
there's
back when sonic won and they redid all
the original you know cgi for sonic
himself like they have to do that like
they could have went out there like that
money on that too yeah they lost
millions because they had to redo
everything that had sonic in it that was
right and because they did that and
because they spent that money i'm like
it don't matter what they do with the
song
because when they don't do it we can
play when they do do it we don't go
watch batman yes paris did you see the
batman and um on the sonic or either one
um i saw the batman i need to go watch
sonic so i'm gonna take my
what was your take on the batman
the batman um it was good it was just
like you know an investigation sort of
movie yeah but i thought it was pretty
good i think they did a good job to sort
of
you know separate yourself from all the
other batman's got you yeah
h member for 22 months thank you sir
lord silver 22 months that's amazing
thank you brother then we got forza
legend once again member for 28 months
crazy sonic about to be all natty on
this box office
about to kill man sonic is about to kill
then we got har gate cheney
with the five dollars that we chat all
this talk about elder and here's an xbox
elden ring global code shout out to
whoever picked up that code if you
picked up the code and managed to get it
you know identify yourself in the chat
yes
he just gave you a game of the year
exactly yeah potential mm-hmm hold on
yeah i got it people knew yeah i got
jumped because people knew i'm bouncing
and like wait a minute hold on
italian clowns five dollars
elden ring is the destiny killer let's
go yo
yo clowns are so messy with anything
with destiny like he has to say
something is the destiny killer that was
part of the reason why i did that for
your intro parents i'm not gonna lie it
did uh hold me back from playing no it's
for you i'll go down here for sure
yeah we got flame five dollar super chat
after nearly a year and a hundred
articles writing for lognet i couldn't
be happier thanks for putting up with me
also welcome back lord sob i'm sorry to
disappoint you that i'm leaving you guys
super chat to read on the way out that i
cannot wait i can imagine
is the truth cop that cog okay the xcode
xb24 have a great show guys glad you're
still alive stop yes
i'll let you know the status of that
when i come back from facts
there we got drawn tj five dollar super
chat morning lords i hope you have a
fire show thank you sir no doubt hold on
let me scroll back
to amblix member for two months
thank you all for everything you do
every week welcome paris to the realm
any thoughts on jeff ross stays gone
joining crystal d as the director
they're already asking
oh god
i got two more
oh no i already know it's good
let's see if i can get prophet lord saab
to read in my super chat salute to the
lords and welcome paris to the realm
hope to catch you guys at pax we will be
there oh you'll be there pull up
pull up everybody yo everybody who who's
in here every single week listens to us
you see us at pax pull up yes and this
especially for the next super chat your
last one continue you know please have
your shirt on too yes
oh no oh no
yes
let me play with your joystick five
dollar super chat
really parrot paris is having too much
fun with it
i'm going to miss you we can always play
co-op if you want that i'll pass on that
sir
you're invited let me play justin
make sure you see some
and yeah if you're covering the facts
fact don't have to worry about my wife
and sister-in-law fawning oversight for
two weeks
[Music]
latino he needs a haircut but
then we got jd gamer five dollar super
chat gotta have lorsav get this on life
is good movement is bad but not delayed
games that are awful make me sad a nice
day alright i appreciate that jd
come on last one we got it we got a boo
yeah
yeah
uh and it's this two dollar super chat
cog how is the powder business
gg.com go get that you know what i'm
saying go i'll go right now
what's up you actually had some
giveaways you're gonna do yeah we got
some giveaways we're gonna do we're
gonna with some stuff going on today so
make sure you go to advanced.com who's
iron lord 20 20 today is the last day go
get that positive powder y'all we got
421 people in here
i know you got to run brother yeah my
brother
i love y'all i will see you guys in a
week and a half everybody in the chat
thank you for being supportive i
appreciate it i will see you guys after
pax and paris yeah and i do appreciate
you not um calling me to help you move
thank you
for that i know y'all busy so i went and
i i got the dude that's retired already
to come help me so
no doubt i know how y'all doing i would
have just brought all of my workers and
we're like there you go
this is extra credit turkeys at the end
of the year
we gotta move we gotta move y'all love
y'all love you brother talk to you later
you already know and of course we have
the incredible hulk of this aka the
excess gamer
the prophet of xbox swami king of the
statues who demands nothing less than
that premium experience and is the
leader of the fraud alert movement
be love it lord keegan how we doing sir
better than ryan garcia oh lord
shout out to combat talk with the king
that comes back next saturday um 10 p.m
live so be there shop with uh spence
versus oogaz
as you can get a chance to hang out with
the king and uh you know a little fight
party talk um ryan garcia came back
after his long delay uh broken hand um
depression
and got in the ring
with uh somebody classified the guy as
the hot dog stand man
excuse me and uh ryan garcia went 12
rounds with him
it was a boring tedious fight and this
is what happens when
you become an instagram sensation and
you're not worried about your passion
and what actually pays the bills
you're in jeopardy of losing that
superstar status sir please stay focused
you're young enough to do so
oh boy what am i playing sir
well you know i've been playing nothing
but elder ring finally
made it to
the uh the mountain top with the giants
now
all these fraud dudes i got to give this
shot we got the fraud alert for you
sprawl dudes i got to give a shout out
to these frauds what is going on because
um a lot of these frauds and i'm telling
my friends please how do i get to the
mountaintop how did well you know you
just gotta you know you
no absolute words
no no no absolute direction
wounded around and ran around and you
know
he's talking about me yeah oh okay
that's what this is okay okay this is
subliminal for you
he knows i didn't want to just call him
out like that
that's my man
okay he's like where's the fire drives
to the bottom right of the snow mountain
i don't know how much more specific i
don't know that's not it yo listen i
swear to god that's not it
all right so shout out to zurich um
megan shaw laughing see the fraud alerts
that's what
she looked at the mega chance how to
make it homie
he's the one that helped me with my
destiny very early on so it's so great
to see that he's uh his channel is
ridiculous and um he helped me get to
the the giants oh you got it
it's two medallions that you get you get
one medallion for the great lift but
there's another uh medallion for the the
lift of road
it's hell to pay to get there
and you know what you think it's you
take a towel or pay to get there wait
till you fight the hidden boss there
yeah it's cool whatever um so he always
does this he wants to put the the fear
of god in you all right so i finally
made it there
but it was hell to pay you know how many
you got to sit down at your controller
you got to hold your controller and no
matter how bad you get your the brakes
beat off you you got to say not today
satan
[Laughter]
and i found out please read all the
items that's inside of your bag
because there was one specific item that
helped me with a boss
i didn't even know i had this item and i
said let me use it because it had his
name on the item
and i used it and it debilitated him
and i was able to get some free hits on
him boy and that saved the day so
just just read your item bag nice for us
guys who don't play souls um
we should reach you to the back that's
it yeah you guys please do because they
don't tell you anything you know this
there's nothing they just like get into
the world and go fight
help um
i saw morbius yes
quickly this is this is another one
oh
for you guys out
there at that rotten tomatoes oh oh tell
me about a character
that
i i love dearly mm-hmm there was a time
when marvel had to uh it was it was
it was so stupid these rules were so
stupid they couldn't do horror in comic
books because these comic books was
geared to children and they had to find
a way around getting vampires they
couldn't do vampires werewolf undead any
of that stuff so that's why morbius is
the living vampire he didn't have to die
to become a vampire is something that
happens to him please go see the movie i
encourage you to go see the movie i
encourage you to educate yourself about
the character before you go see the
movie before you disappoint yourself
going in to see the movie his moveset is
100 percent the character his visuals j
oh my god jared leto is the probably the
greatest actor in the world
um
he looks just like morbius okay
because the acting was on point oh so
you're failing this is not the power of
opinion
i'm i'm living in an age where i picked
up a book as a child as a six or
seven-year-old child and this character
that i'm seeing in this book this little
known character there's not an a plus
character right he's a c-level uh
spider-man character you know he's not
dr octopus he's not the vulture
um and the fact that he gets a movie his
own movie
it's it's amazing to me so i'm sitting
there appreciative that whoever pushed
for this was the same kid that was
sitting there that was reading these
books that was feeling this and they
they actually incorporated the purple in
it at the end so it's little touches
that was was for me throughout the whole
movie um how they depict his power set
the problem that individuals have and
i've read it okay didn't like how
powerful he was
that's his set that's his power set and
you got to appreciate how strong
spider-man is to overcome that yeah i
didn't get spider-man is this the origin
film anyway i go on to say that stay to
the last two end credit scenes it sets
up a new universe shout out to andrew
garfield i cannot wait for something
powerful to happen in your life because
i do love you as spider-man and i hope
this is pushing towards that no doubt um
as a real fan and i and i brought these
out for paris
of the marvel universe you know
if you got milner you got to have
stormbreaker
so i brought those out for that and i
knew you're a true fan of marvel and
i wanted to actually opinion on the
movie what did you just very really
quick um what did you think about the
movie i'm pretty sure that you saw it
what did you think well uh for more
videos i have not seen it yet oh okay
okay so that's one movie that i thought
that's on my bucket list i just been i
haven't had the time to go see it yet
but i was planning to see it this
weekend but then sonic's out so i've
gotta i had to make a decision yeah i
might just go see it late at night
maybe to tonight yeah you know
yes i might go see it tonight
later on it's live late so
um but
i've read the opinions um in our group
there's a lot of back and forth on it uh
people you know like it some people
hate it or some people that was okay
something very polarizing
it's a smorgasbord of uh opinions about
it right right
um i i don't like movies you know movies
in the marvel industry to well the
marvel universe that fell at all right
so um and i don't listen to rotten
tomatoes that often because they're
thank you they're just
yeah some of them are just way off and
then they base their opinion on
you know no actual facts
yeah that's that's that's what our
problem got right i'll tell you that
you two are the most knowledgeable uh
cinematic universe people i know so i do
absolutely notice i defer to both the
knowledges here i know the iron man dude
has a red suit hulk is green
[Laughter]
hit me up after you see it yeah we'll do
it look we got him i will i will i'll
hit you up no doubt and i ain't
introduced to the damn self um the game
relationship but you know me here we go
look out so um
shout out to maddie plays we had a good
one she's breaking down the game pass
features and we actually shame gamers
who don't who mute game music which is
pretty funny so go check that out um
also on the uh patreon for defining duke
ultimate we had chris ray gun we had
imantis we did the official witch queen
spoiler cast go check that out shame
game yeah anybody who mutes game music
we had to shame you it was a segment it
was hilarious
sinister does it we're going to get him
anyway i was going to say yeah sinister
is a main offender if you're listening
sinister we i i named you um anyway
mutant destiny
that's
music
crime like he's he's absolutely
ridiculous
salute to all be boxes and um
the hell be down at busy work week shout
out to tiddly who they had on really
cool for me it's just been mlb the show
crusader kings three and of course still
sneaking in uh destiny when i can uh we
do have a giveaway that we're gonna be
doing so the first seven lords who cop
some ilp merch now when you cop the
merch make sure you leave a comment and
your twitter handle five remember excuse
me correct five thank you that is five
thank you for that correction that was
only five only five there's only five
only five of you guys so the first five
lords who cop some ilp
merch from the store links in the
description at the top go click that
especially if you're coming to patch cop
a pack shirt right okay you know what
i'm saying say what's up i would tell
you to do so um
that way when you take a picture you
just don't look out of sorts exactly so
the first five who cops have merch and
then you know a little alert comes up
for us make sure you put your twitter
handle and leave a comment and we will
also hook you up with some gift cards or
a 40 gift card for that
that's 40 dollars for that advanced gg
what i'm saying get you some energy get
you some focus more than the shirt
so if you're copping something right now
you're getting something for free this
is basically just go do your thing do
your thing like i said support the laws
like i said if you're a gamer if you're
not into a workout point do you lose
focus it's that it's a great natural
substitute as opposed to you're not into
working out whatever what i suggest you
do to focus uh get get get the stuff and
then send it to me
and in that way that way you can
ingratiate yourself to the king
you can still support this
and if you're if you are a person who
likes to work out you can use the energy
lab so salute go get that you already
know so we have uh be labored long
enough we got to get into the main event
we have a very patient guest so now that
we got into what the laws have been
planned we got to focus on lord paris
lockhart his video game system history
passion for the mcu which we kind of
learned about and of course what led him
as senior program manager for game
streaming at xbox so lord lockheed let's
start from the very beginning what was
your video game system history and what
got you into gaming sir
oh man uh
atari that's where it all started for me
um actually i didn't have one one of the
kids in our neighborhood had one
um and we all congregated over to his
house and we were
just
you know standing by we're like well
this is real like this is we can do some
things right you know you know paris one
time
i won't have a guest on that he was that
dude that had
but we know we all had like a lot of us
had that one friend you know king was
that for us right where it's like you go
to see the the tech but it says so tell
me tell your story i'm sorry yeah yeah
yeah so you know he uh he had it we'd
everybody come over and play and you
know as kids during the summertime we
that's what we did it was like
we're over there and then when nintendo
came out he got the first nintendo but
everybody else started getting nintendo
yeah um so we all were playing nintendo
and you know super mario brothers that's
you know that's where it started and
yeah
let me ask you a question because all
right so you you you went from the atari
you know y'all hanging out um he had
pitfall harry pretty sure everybody had
pitfalls
and all that stuff so so the question is
did you witness or did you even uh know
that we had a the great crash after e.t
uh before the uh the nintendo came out
because nintendo came out after the
crash when the market yeah
back then when i was i didn't even you
know i wouldn't i wouldn't i was
oblivious to all that yeah even though
there was a crash i just knew that a
couple years came went by nintendo was
out
i didn't even know the crash so when
people were saying i was like for real i
was living it
right yeah it was yeah you know i was
that young you know but um
look at that pay attention to like you
know what was going on in the gaming
industry back then it was more of just
like oh this new system's out can i get
one no
what do i gotta do to get one right good
grades you gotta you gotta clean up the
house you gotta not talk back
long laundry list so
christmas next thing you know it was
finally there so um yes we got one and
that was the nes
yes okay
first did you get robbed with it or in
the light gun or just the the console i
just got the console two controllers
okay nice
and super mario brothers i think that
was the default game um and then you
know so then it went on like the rest of
the neighborhood got one and then we
started playing tecmo bowl
yeah
competitions let's go on season wait
hold on
oh man you know what it all would depend
on who i was playing against
he was a matchup guy
i was a match-up guy because i was
really good at that game i mean i was
just
dominant i got to the point where i
could just beat people with anybody
right so right
i just was like okay whoever you play
with and if i know their skill level
yeah i would be not so great of a team
because it would just be a blowout
unless they talk trash and i'm gonna go
with my heavy hitters and then i'm just
gonna win but they can play with the
raiders all they want i'm just gonna
play bears defense and i'm gonna win
so yeah it doesn't it doesn't matter so
it was like whoever wanted something i
got you
you know i but i kept it easy i kept on
playing you know the football games like
then i was just like excel like too bad
they didn't have real tournaments right
all back there technical tournaments
have been crazy
crazy
once you break through that line your
little man get to go
remember because he reminds us of our
close childhood friend mr huh whenever
he had a play on you and the offensive
line his offensive line was doing a good
job he would run with the running back
and be like hold him
so we'd get annoyed whenever he'd get a
big run off because basically the ai
logic with the offensive line like it
was very simple like if they won the
match up they held it forever and they
run it
could run so it was just one of the
funny moments
i'm so great it is so crazy you remember
that because i remember him pissing me
yeah and it was just like you couldn't
do nothing because it was a perfect play
call against whatever you picked what
continue
yeah yeah
that's crazy on that game sort of the ai
on that game was based on how how it
worked yeah the zigzag you can run all
the way down the field with bo run all
the way back
bo jackson was ridiculous give us some
of the nes titles man give us some other
edius titles
oh um uh
what else we got we got double dribble
oh
double dribble so he was a sports fan
yeah back then yeah i played a lot of
the sports games but i didn't get
legends of zelda okay eventually you
know so um but back then it was all
sports right yeah let me actually
dribble
did you did you get a chance to see okay
all right say out of my my one of my
best friends as a child calvin
washington love him to death that's the
first time i got a chance to see double
dribble right
and
i didn't know when he got the cartridge
we you know you
you get it you blow it
right
and you put it in
and
you know we were shooting for a while
and then i had made a breakaway to the
rim
tell me about that first time you made a
break away to the rim
i was a dunk it was like i made sure i
got to a certain part of the team
the first time you saw it the character
get big and it goes bam bam bam
yeah it was the most electrifying yes
thing
for four four but i i've see i wasn't a
super sports fan back then
but that he got so paused he got so big
on the screen and he dunked the ball i
was like oh this is amazing we played
that game hours on yeah and
one of the best games in it man thank
you for breaking no double dribble
doesn't get his flowers yeah continue
yeah yeah you know the three-point
shooting the yeah you can like hover in
the air yeah
yeah yeah yeah
from blocking your shot
you move over in the sky yeah yeah
passes against one another it was it was
it was great you know there's just some
shots on that game you just knew you
weren't going to make
like anything top of the key middle key
you ain't going to make it
shout out to the shot shot chart
ai
yeah
so you had those
legend of zelda of course uh castlevania
you know it started you know as you got
older these newer games started coming
out so i just started uh playing those
and then there was a little gap and then
i had then i got sega right yeah
once it came out it was yeah second
genesis
i mean i had the game boy but you know
game boy was just something that you
know just played and yeah
that's all i had on lunchroom stuff yeah
yeah but once in high school it was all
it was all about sega got serious
altered beasts golden axe sonic
all those games it was just
constant spider-man
yes genesis spiderman
very underrated yes and i believe had
venom in it as well
you talk about a maximum carnage and
that's not that was the
first he talked about the first vitamin
spiderman it had venom in it yeah yeah
i believe i have been a minute and it
was i gotta check it out we gotta check
out that first
[Laughter]
got to get the cartridges for your
things you run out you fight the
crocodile you know all those dudes so
yeah it was good yes
so from genesis then what else we went
on too
uh from genesis it was placed close
playstation and
nintendo okay um
gamecube so you got them at the same
time or you got the playstation 4 it was
playstation first okay so playstation's
first yeah was it was it a launch uh
console for you or no it wasn't a launch
it was just eventually we just got it
okay and got it and then um i was
playing uh
you know i think i don't know but i
think that might have been playstation 2
with jet moto okay yeah oh yeah that was
it no jet motor was in playstation one
um uh
did you play paraphernalia
what's that parappa the rapper
i haven't played that one okay that was
the first game
i brought that shout out to [ __ ] i
brought that game over and um it was a
because i had the japanese version of
the of the console right so okay
we had to put the little rubber in the
back to play the american games
uh so i did that and
i i have parappa rapper it's the first
rhythm game that we had and we completed
this game but it was made out of paper
mache and
i found it amazing that it was kitty rap
but it was intricate and it was good and
we had to be on beat with it so it was
the first introduction to us to um that
rhythm type of game stuff so i i got a
little puppet upstairs inside of my room
pause guys don't even be funny with the
puppet
[Laughter]
you're stupid
[Laughter]
like was it you got both at the same
time because i know she had the genesis
gap like what was the space between you
know getting into the playstation and
nintendo ecosystems at that point oh yes
it was just genesis and then
then the playstation came out because we
were talking about cds i think i worked
at kmart when the playstation game like
i was working at kmart when playstation
came out and i bought one there so i
used my paychecks to buy one they're
flying off the shelves and people were
buying them i was like nice oh and i
worked in electronics so i was always
playing inside the store nice i worked
there so i was just like i might as well
just go ahead and get one i had to like
lose my little 15 discount
employee perks
special
that's how i used to get all my games
i'm waiting for the blue light specials
to go i know it's coming i know it's ah
let me put this to the side this is my
stack
of insider knowledge yeah
hold on hold on he's about to give us
some go ahead go ahead yeah best believe
i would i would do that like there's a
layaway right that came on had the
layaway and i worked there too so
i would just go put stuff on lay away
and just do it and then and or
and i worked in layaway i knew people
weren't coming back to pick these
i respect that i'll respect okay
go back up to the farm
bam let's go i heard he moved
[Laughter]
salute
because you're listening we didn't have
cell phones back then they told us well
we had a camera we walked off the days
on tuesday baby
he had one of those brick walls and this
giant calendar it's like yeah every day
something else that was like
i respect it i respect it that way it's
crazy only that that really got me about
layaway is that when people would put
that lawn furniture on right away so i
had to go get it yeah put it upstairs
right and then you know i got all this
lawn furniture up there taking up all
the
and i'll be space for them to cancel it
off but somebody come back and put a
dollar on and i'm like come on
to extend it for another month i'm like
no no i'll respect that i'll respect
that
you got the playstation
and you got the gamecube uh what
the gamecube was a little bit different
what enticed you to get the gamecube
what was it was that oh um uh uh what's
the game uh luigi's popular racing game
oh wait wait um where's it with that oh
f-zero well i said it was super nintendo
but i'm trying to go no no no no they
had that f-zero for the game oh what
about mario kart
mario kart mario kart that's the only
game we play on gamecube
everybody come over everybody will play
you know we just hang out and just play
uh mario kart you know that's okay fire
so we lose or get off that's the card
as the console owner did you tell them
that they had to bring their own
controller yes um i know i always tried
to keep controllers i always got awesome
oh he's good see you you are mr hop yeah
he must be your spiritual successor all
right so yeah for me and for for cognito
we would tell people that they had to
bring their own controller
all right i'm not investing in you
you're investing yourself right i'm
invested in the console right so but mr
ha
would have controllers laid out for
and then like when i went to
when i would go to people's houses i
bring my own control oh man yeah he's
just the same he's the same yeah because
it's like he had to try because i know
how the button
is broken
that is literally mr
t hi we gonna make mr hot listen to this
episode because it's the same
sensibility it's like that's that
personal control that you got that
relationship you know how it feels and
yeah
i got you
i got nothing worse
there's nothing worse than trying to do
that turn on mario kart and you can't
because the controller jack
there will be no loss blamed on the
controller of another
we'll find something else to blame it on
dude
i want to ask you really quick in the
sense of um i know we didn't get to yet
but like just a 32-bit error it was
interesting i always felt you know 32
but there was some fringe stuff going on
and then also i wanted to ask you so
first was like turbografx16 did any of
that get in the mix and then also i know
there's some it doesn't get a lot of
love but some people did have it was the
three deal so those two systems were the
experience with
yeah well a couple of my friends had
trouble graphics 16 i didn't get it um
uh and and i didn't touch the ndo
um
yeah seven hundred dollars was not in my
price range so it says i'm gonna also
assume the dog was out of the question
no neo gm
oh he caught me mid
try to get a gauge of eddie because you
know we all got our gaps and stuff like
that but i was just trying to see okay
just want to make sure we hit that and
that kind of thing and then also um i
know you mentioned game boy you know
saying but on portables you know we had
i think we had turbo express we had
atari links it was game gear
any outside of game boy did any other
portables kind of sneak into the
ecosystem for more lucky
um no it was just uh just gamecube i
mean just the game boy got you okay uh i
didn't play anything else um i i
remember others were out there i seen
them you know working out like like i
said i worked at camera we had all the
all the systems but no i didn't uh get
into any of them
xbox era so um were you there for the
for the o.g
so this is what so my story is so after
i um
uh graduated high school um
i i joined the navy oh i served eight
years in the navy absolutely my first
and my first four years um i was
stationed in japan oh so i was in
yokosuka tokyo oh that's i'll station
yokosuka but tokyo i could go all those
[Laughter]
they were so far ahead of us in the
united states on tech like their cell
phones they were already texting and
taking pictures wow
but we were even there like we they even
had they had like you know i was you
know
um out there and they were there people
they would watch reality tv what and i
would be like
what are we watching and they're like oh
there's just people in the house talking
and doing stuff
i'm like
this ain't a show they're like no this
is this is reality tv and i'm like
nobody would ever watch this in the
states
shut up fast forward
wow a lot of that stuff a lot of the
stuff over there they sort of uh they
were already on so this already talks
about tech and games like in japan
video game arcades
talk to me about it's my dream i've
never done this yeah
you didn't need a system out there
because you just walked down the street
and there's just arcades all over the
place
going to arcades you got straightforward
you got every game like every game what
the name of the spots like what was that
what was the like i mean you know
location certain cities little cows okay
just any any city basically almost every
city had video game arcades wow like you
get off the train you go hit the arcade
what we would do before we go to the
club
yo boy you're a young boy he was outside
come on man
you were stationed there you get out you
go out because you know you go to work
and you get off and then oh friday
saturday night
yeah so you got the uh you go out there
i got a different impression like living
in new york we know when the navy's in
there yeah what is it fleet the hills
[Laughter]
that's the fleet week now we would go
places where we'd have to keep our
uniform but with your station there
you're there yeah oh okay yeah you don't
got to do that so we'll be out there we
you know we would go play racing there's
like this like four player race car game
yeah it was epic right and i never had
seen anything like this in my life but
it was like a like a daytona game
you talk about super g probably right
yeah possibly you had the rc program
type field but it was it was a racing
storm car races so like if you crash and
damage your car up
you hit the pit stop
your car is going to go faster than
everybody else so if you get pass up a
lap you go and catch and pass everybody
yeah oh wow to get you back into the
race and then you're like in the race so
you never sort of out out of it that's a
catch-up mechanic
so what you know four people if you're
playing with four people before one of
you four are going to finish
[Music]
you was in the cutting edge of
the large arcade machines well because
here in the states while you was there
here in the states we will get sporadic
uh drops
of uh large arcade machines the first
one that i saw and i played in was the
star wars one
that you sit down yeah from i think sega
made it and then um it started uh
escalating from there but you were in
the cutting edge of it because i'm
pretty sure that your arcade rooms were
like vastly larger and you know because
we would go down to times square where
probably had uh 15 to 20 arcade rooms
down there so you're at the the the apex
of it um
what was what was the biggest
contraption pause that you uh sat in
well besides the the four player uh
co-op um race game machine
the singular one because i got into one
that was like a vr or like mech thing
did you get into anything like that um
let me recall um there's just so many of
them are so many games uh
i know uh
what was time crisis i don't know that
yeah the light gun crisis was already
time crisis that was big i remember that
one yeah um there was game similar to
like time crisis like single-player
games it was like random like
japanese shooting games and stuff like
that where you're sure you know
um
there was uh the dancing games
that was something they were already up
on that uh
just trying to think i loved it most
most games i played were fighting games
and the only game i was playing was
street fighter oh
the only reason i was playing street
fighter was i think a street fighter
three or four four okay
because
that's where the competition was at
boy those dudes man if they you go in
there and you beat like you're an
american yeah yeah you're american you
go in there you beat one of those dudes
they take it ashamed
[Music]
you know it's funny you say that i love
that you said it because you know for me
fighting game is a deer and deer and you
know the tekken scene new york city
chinatown fair
you know that was a thing the arcade
competitive scene right so i'm just
picturing you and you're in japan right
and i'm not a street fighter guy like
street fighter is a different skill set
it's zoning it's the fire ball it's it's
levels to it i was never good at it i
give you guys all the props street
fighter fight fight game fighters are
amazing but like i know how competitive
that seat is so if you're now in japan
in its hey the best of the best and
there's something about
that gathering the the people of the
world
you know i wasn't gonna say it but
like
a lot of that stuff their people made it
right yeah it's like we made it it's
like but we beat you out of any way
here's the thing attic right there's
reputations on the line because there's
a certain it's a certain as a certain
aura of the best player at that arcade
right or the top players and when they
come on they come on the sticks and
everybody look around like yeah
such-and-such is about to get on you
know so so here comes lord paris you
don't say that what was the character
what was the character break it down oh
i would be ken just to even make it even
worse for him because
i'm really sticking this american
nonsense
i could just hear them in the background
like whispering each other i wish that
america would go home
the first couple times i would go in
there because you know like after work
you don't want to do anything you're
just hanging out so i just don't hit the
arcades and stuff like that the first
couple times i've been going there man
they would just they would just demolish
me i was like you know what
let me go in here during some
dojo
let's go
let me learn these sticks yes i would go
in and then every random person that
would come in and i would you know hang
with them or even beat them you could
tell that they were just something maybe
they were doing what i was doing
because there's a prime time yeah
there's a certain hour
the the yeah dudes would be in there
they'll all be having fun and
i put my quarter my little japanese but
that quote up
out of curiosity did any of them teach
you like anything or was it like
strictly competitive
there's no conversation except
except when you lose they say something
in japanese which probably would say
like you suck
break down the moment now so now you're
putting in the work right you're going
in this offline oh man this is good
you're coming back to the arcade now you
know you're ready your ken is right i
put it on my little quarter and then
these guys was playing and then
i beat the first dude the first dude i
know i beat him before okay so i beat
him the mini band
the next guy came on but the head dude
the dude that's nice because they sent
the minions first to test yes
i ran through them all and then he was
he had this quarter up he took it off
and he yelled out another dude to put it
on he really want to touch the tip
he wanted
you know he wanted the side i was on
yeah okay oh left side left side
let's go
he only win
you can expose someone in the fighting
game community
by jumping to the other side because
some people are so conditioned to the
left side and they can't play the other
side and they're not as dominant but
this is great
yeah yeah so he um
so i knew he wanted that side so i was
like do you want me to switch we can
switch oh
everybody was looking at him like hey
just play so he was like oh yeah this is
gonna be easy work he thought it's gonna
be easy work oh he won the first round
he won the first round really quick i
was like okay so i just started i was
like you know what i mean
i was using ken he was using right here
okay okay okay
don't worry
usually right you or he was using
don't like paris you threw that first
match to give him too much confidence
i wanted to smoke him undefeated i
wanted to go through them
was your confidence a little shaken no
no because i just i went aggressive okay
yeah i just went after him to try to see
how he would and plus then i switched
sides right so i needed to get my the
good work
yeah okay okay go ahead okay working it
out yeah so the second match second
round i played defense the whole time so
right i was like you know what yeah i
was blocking and then
i was getting it with petty shots
and then i snuck in one and i hit him
with a combo and threw him and beat him
and he was like oh dude
yeah he's you know why is she fighting
that's kind of what he said
okay so
let me tell you a little there's a
little story here there's a little story
here don't cheese me bro so over here in
the states while you're doing that over
here in the states
when they turtle and you tap them and
they turtle
automatic grow yes you can grab them
toss them right so that's over here they
call it cheesing yeah and it's you can't
get out of it
so i understand his frustration
well i mean i had to do it that round i
mean you know
you gotta do what you got it's in the
game
he's done the same thing to people right
his powers like this level and he
defensively yeah
you know and be just blocking because
after a certain time you're you're
powering them decrease on blocks yes
right
the lower your power is the last time
your power go down because you're
blocking so
you know uh the third round
i was thinking i was like oh i'm gonna
go i'm going after him i went after him
and i beat him almost perfect then
man
oh you typical american all
demonstrative with it
you know
[Music]
dude that you beat probably didn't even
hear anything you say he's just looking
at the screen just denial
he was he was mad
he was mad all his friends are mad and
they were like no come back and play
something i'm done
shout out shout out to powers
you took the w as i know i'm i'm good
i'll be back now i'll be back next week
you gonna hold you're gonna rub this all
in your chest
have a good night have a good day
it reminds me of a karate movie when we
fight the boss in the beginning and he
he mops the floor with you but you guys
they get you trained
back in the last half an hour with a
movie
you're a salute to your petty though i
gotta respect your penny
man
that was good that was a great story
salute man yeah it was a thing just to
cap off that um
you know i would still come in during
our off times you know still playing
stuff like that
[Laughter]
the guy that was the main the guy that
pretty much owned the arcade he was the
champ right right right he came in and
he gave me some uh shook my hand it was
like great game the other day oh what
right now i was like we could play but i
was like you know he was like oh no no
no no i'm gonna play something else but
um uh yeah he he came in and uh
shouldn't knock the confidence out of
him yeah yeah but man he's like you know
i'm not losing to you because uh in our
tradition i have to give you my arcade
[Laughter]
he was he was a man though i'm not going
to lie he was the man you beat everybody
in there but you know he came back and i
was just like you know
uh i felt so happy he was like you you
come in and practice i was like yes
i come in and practice you know he
probably was too he respected you for
learning his game so yeah yeah he he
looked at you coming he's probably he's
probably looking at you as a young potty
long like you coming in every day after
you got your butt what he saw you lose
yeah like hmm i wonder if this american
will be back and then you came back in
the next day you study it he's like
i think i have a champion here
i mean he would serve all the other
dudes up from the navy come in there
they'd be thinking oh i'm a big bad dude
they were getting work i was just like
you guys are just losing your money i
was like you guys are getting work
you got to take your time and they were
like did you beat i'll say yeah dude i'm
doing it i'm like no i know you guys
going you get it you got it you're good
well i salute you man i've been working
i missed the i missed that era and um
i'm glad you brought that up because
it's a long lost errand it's a shame
like sometimes i feel like this
generation
never experienced that true competitive
monoi model it's different because don't
get me wrong no respect to the esport
community i respect them you know but
it's like the arcade the pressure
you know what i'm saying and being
physically next to someone and i know
now you know obviously pretty pandemic
they were starting to bring that back
and that's what esports is growing back
but it it's different man and i miss
that energy and to see you do that you
know over japan the height of it during
the popularity
is really amazing brother so i'm glad
you brought you you shared that arcade
story absolutely awesome and and that
whole story
the raging war of xbox was going on yes
continue which we got to get back on
point yes yes yes
yes
we went left thank you thank you
yeah yeah yeah yeah i think uh
yeah when i i moved back to i came back
to the states when xbox had came out and
i was in san diego um but i had the
playstation uh three
oh okay i was already a playstation dude
and
oh and your money was right because that
was like seven hundred dollars yeah
right yeah that's right
and i was you know playing in japan
everybody had playstations right
everybody had playstation playstation 3
came out in japan
like about a year or so or something
like that before it came out in the
states so it was a little yeah yes that
one year yep correct so the question is
did you buy your playstation there or
did you buy your place and when you came
here i bought my playstation when i came
here but everybody on the sh
on the ship they would buy their they
bought their playstations i didn't have
to buy one so nice and our what happened
somebody in our department would buy one
you know and then we would just buy
games they were all japanese games
anyway so we had to you know to learn
the games yeah just play yeah so um
that's when i came back that's first
thing i bought i was about to play 63.
it's okay okay yeah so i had the
playstation um
socom whoa
that was a wonderful game that was the
that was it that was the game that
soaked on one token
classics that's
i would be up at three o'clock in the
morning and uh you know me and kyle talk
or whatever we're gonna get on we're
gonna play and that was the first like
network game yeah and we it was just
like this trench that you would sit in
the hallway i would just sit in the
bushes
i know you know about it you know about
the long hallway it was like little
spots that you would get your fight to
get to these spots and you try to blow
people up to get out of those spots all
the grenades land the mines protect the
bomb no doubt thank you man
so you're in place there's a little more
strategy because one death you got to
wait yes yes i think there isn't that
sort of rapid respawn that you go
through with some of the games right
it's like you die it's like oh man they
need to
yes
you know
that's automatically on so you throw
that grenade not knowing
everybody
and kill two year old man
and they're like bro you can hear them
in your headset man
they think that your team killing on
purpose yeah
so you went through that era you go
through the show calls whatever so how
did it go
i'm curious how did it get into the mix
oh the xbox yeah yeah yeah so um um as
i'm playing playstation all my friends
here in seattle because this is where i
grew up at and i live then i you know i
moved to alaska and uh then that's where
i joined the military from and that's
where i graduated high school from that
gotcha you went up to alaska yeah okay
so okay
yeah
probably like close to one of the only
black people in japan
yeah
one of the only black people in
alaska face of us all over what is up
okay i've always been curious about
alaska yeah
just just just give me a one day overlap
just one day i notice it's detracting
but i've always literally been real
curious is it as barren as people say
what what is it what is it it's
there's a like so you live in anchorage
anchorage is a city so it's a city just
like anywhere else in downtown
downtown's not that big it's small yeah
um
people you know you got bars and just
everyday life is the same um it's just
during the winter time it's snow
like i'm sure it snows in new york so
it's no it's just another this is a
different level is it is it different
level cold and snow wait wait wait wait
wait
because i think
all right this is how ignorant i am
right i'm thinking of snow all the time
oh no
oh okay that's the north pole once you
get up to the north pole the northern
part of alaska like the north pole area
that's
uh yeah i think we generalized the
entire stage
i mean that that's my this is my
curiosity to it yeah so you're like you
like it
yeah the summer's out there a while
because the the time differences uh uh
changes where
like you'll be 11 o'clock at night and
it'd still be light outside right
yeah so time just fly by you're out
there having fun with your friends and
doing stuff
that's 11.
or like you like you go out to a club or
something like that you it's 11 and you
come outside it's 2 a.m and it's white
it's like 3
a lot of friends still you know
communicate with a lot of people out
there try to go up there every once in a
while and the visit so yeah yeah
good place to raise kids if you have
kids if you're looking for something to
just sort of just
relax relax and chill out yeah
absolutely so you come back
you know if you ever get an opportunity
though up there you do some fishing
fishing is always good so just see that
now that's definitely a thought because
my whole thought of alaska was polar
bears snow all the time igloos
and i know that that's that's probably
an ignorant thought but this is what
i've been doing
he said y'all killing me i'm a black
dude in alaska right now and that's he's
the japan and i'm gaming come on
we got to get back on track we just see
you i can just see king out there making
it igloo right now i'm done
we gotta we gotta refocus
time time we gotta get this interview
back on track so look we got that the
thing is that we we're leading about now
to xbox you said you come back home in
the playstation ecosystem and yeah now
watch too all my friends are playing
xbox they all got xbox 360.
and they're like oh man you should come
play and you know once we played some of
the multiplayer games like 2k oh
actually nba live and 2k and stuff like
that
we were playing a basketball games we
play on
xbox because that's all they had and
that's why i would go to play okay um
when they would come over i would just
have socom
i got you
yeah that's it right um and then they
would play um you know we played madden
i was like oh man i gotta remember all
these buttons why don't you just go buy
a xbox and i was like no i'm not buying
an xbox yet
i love it i know you already have been
indoctrinated
the japanese culture let's go let's go
yeah i was like no i'm not yet not yet
you know i'm gonna get one and they're
like come on man you gotta play you
gotta play halo yeah once we started
playing halo
um i was like i was hooked i was like
shut up that's that's that's it so
instead of just buying just any old
normal xbox that you know you could buy
at the stores you got i went and bought
the uh
uh
the uh there's one online
thing was on amazon i found one without
looking to buy one and it was the uh
the rtd2 oh
the star wars one
yeah when you when you press the button
yeah yeah that's the first xbox i bought
uh mm-hmm
yeah so anybody i didn't have the xbox
og that's like what's the xbox one yeah
so you got 360. yeah
okay gotcha okay so i didn't get i i
didn't buy the og xbox i've got the 360.
that's any red ring of death
i went to the whole 360 generation with
not one ring of death wow oh my god you
lucked out you definitely looked up now
the rtd2 one never expands me to death
but my friends their xboxes we
uh got ringing back but we figured out
we could watch some youtube videos
in the blanket
and the whole thing you got to work and
it came back on we're like here we go
there was one time we ran cover act
microsoft actually uh repaired his and
send it back and then like a couple
months later got ring of death and then
we just went back to the uh tile thing
um like that the ones i had i didn't i
didn't experience it oh that's okay so
you lucked out you looked at football so
from that point on you know you're now
in the xbox ecosystem
halo brings you in you know that kind of
stuff you know obviously this is already
xbox live heavy at xbox live you know
360 is hitting its try what you know
where you also attracted to like yes
what were the other titles on the 360
that once you started opening yourself
up to the platform because you were a
playstation guy
like what what what made you appreciate
360.
um well so if it's what it was halo i'm
just gonna say it was halo yeah it was
halo then it was gears
and then there was some of the other
party games were you know cross-platform
games madden
uh 2k so all those like the mad games i
still was heavy on those so
i just was like okay well i can still
play manic still do all the things i
want to do but the cool thing with it
for me was like my
my uh email address all that stuff was
attached to yes my account so i could
get all that stuff email all that stuff
and it was easy for me to pour all that
stuff over it's easy to operate
within the microsoft ecosystem all my
outlook and all that stuff was right it
just was easy for me so yeah um yeah and
it just started making more sense and
then i started just playing more xbox
games and
less playstation games um and then i
think what happened uh sony had got
hacked back then
[Music]
tony had got hats and when they got
hacked i didn't even i was like
i don't even know what to do anymore
right yeah and i was kind of upset that
what they did to socom they killed the
uh yeah yeah the studio
and then they made suck on four and i
was that wasn't great
yeah and and i just was like you know
every all my friends are already playing
xbox i'm just gonna move them over there
i like games anyway so it was easy for
me to easier transition no doubt no
doubt man look tremendous game of
history you know we could go on and on
with you
this is insane history we have to bring
him back because there's more questions
i really would ask but it's like this
would be a five-hour when i can't do
that so
what we're gonna do is um i gotta
transition out to the actual journey
right so oh yeah you know you're doing
this you oversee navy guy
i.t guy retail you're all over you got
like a very you know cool history it's
very eclectic but like now what was his
journey now to microsoft like to now
lead you in that direction and then
ultimately become the senior program
manager for cloud streaming yeah yeah so
um yeah working at uh like i worked as
an i.t manager for a company for like
five years and um
my dream was always to work at microsoft
back when i was in the navy i was
telling people i was like i'm gonna be
working for microsoft yeah
as we're loading windows nt 4.0 whoa
okay okay windows windows 2000 on our
servers
exchange 5.5 for anybody that knows
anybody i know what you're talking about
right now let's go microsoft exchange
servers and all that stuff so as i'm
working back then i'm like you know i'm
going to work for this company i'm like
they're based in seattle it's my
hometown i got it that's just like i got
to do it so um
you know in the navy i took a bunch of
certification courses took the uh get
the certification i got my bachelor's
degree so when i came back
um i didn't know where i was sort of
like where i was at and then what it
actually took to write work at microsoft
because i just was maybe it was a lot of
self
you know
i didn't have the self confidence
because i thought you know you needed to
be sort of some yell or hard right big
school yeah like no no that's that's
real that's real brown you know
the warden business school and all that
stuff so you know
you see
you see all the people you see on tv and
all the stuff like that you just see
people from those schools right right so
it was it was intimidating right um so i
never really applied um and i was like
i'll just stick in my lane
um and do all the stuff that i know how
to do right um but then i was like got
to a point they're like you know i
talked to a few people that i met just
like at a bar they're like oh yeah you
you should definitely try to apply just
random people that you being out so
everybody either works on microsoft and
amazon or whatever yeah yeah and i was
like okay i'll get over this sort of
self-doubt
um
yeah so before that i went and got my
masters oh
okay i can boost my resume so i
you know it took two years to do that
all my saturdays were gone for two years
sacrifice
yeah so sacrifice yeah so i did that
um uh i think did i take any more
certificates i don't think i took any
more certification so i actually went
through the interview process
a couple of roles um gotta hire but then
there were some issues that went on like
they had hiring so i had to wait like
another year and a half i'm so
frustrated yeah so yeah
yeah yeah i finally got in and it was
like i was like yes i'm here and i was
like this ain't it
though you you in the building what
happened i'm in the building i'm in the
building but this ain't it i was like i
gotta work in gaming i gotta get over
there
got to get there so that was my uh
that was the thing that i uh
really really wanted to do
um and and i talked with you know
people within the gaming teams and try
to understand sort of like different
jobs and stuff like that i might even
talk with phil nice it was like you
should come over and you know him saying
you should come over it's different
right
it doesn't matter differently
you should find a job in here right and
go through the go through the process
you know
it was good to hear that you know and
stuff like that so i uh i did what i had
to do um
found a role talked with a lot of people
got to know people networked nice um uh
you know went and took a a
a program manager uh
of course at the uw okay just uh
because as you're a program manager
there's certain things you got to unlock
because that's different from just being
like an i.t manager or something someone
that's being support
you know your thought process is
different you think about things in a
different way because you want to fix
things quickly and support like if
somebody gets yeah
but as a
program manager you take that as
feedback and you think about the bigger
picture of trying to
fix a larger a larger issue
conceptualized long-term thinking bigger
picture
yeah the vision and then
the poor strategy that not just fixes
that but improves
stuff stuff across the board so
as you as i'm working through that you
know i i got on with xcloud and
went through that process
and uh
i was excited because i was like you
know this is the next generation of
gaming for us
something brand new we're still in beta
right now
um so it's just like you know we there
was a startup mentality um working on
here but now we're we're turning it into
a product and it's something that you
know i'm very excited about and the
things that we're doing in x-cloud oh
it's just good transition brother good
job i've got to ask you a couple
questions in that respect because um you
know
hearing the story is amazing and then
obviously what you guys have pioneered
in this space is is truly amazing and i
want to start first with the challenges
because um you know what was maybe some
of the initial challenges when you
joined the team from a cloud streaming
standpoint you know or maybe just doing
particularly during your tenure when you
when you john joined the team you know
that you guys faced you know what i'm
saying so like any particular thing i
know initially i remember you know you
guys were on ios you know at one point
you know it was just android only there
was a lot of things going on so like
tell us some of the initial challenges
you remember facing well i mean it's
stuff that's well publicized is that the
fact that we were we're not able to
build an app on
ios right right um apple
blocked us from doing that yeah that's a
huge huge market as well yeah yeah
there's you know they there's a lot that
goes on between that i
i can't form my campaign
we don't get you jumping right there all
right so we had to figure out another
way to do it and that's just using the
browser ios or if you have edge browser
on your on your ios phone you know the
uh safari browser so you can go to and
you can still play xcloud that way right
right
there's no restrictions on that sort of
thing for us um but android we're able
to build an app you can still play with
your uh edge browsers or
chrome browser right all the browsers
pretty much you can play so so you was
there at the the point where you found
out that you can go through a browser
what was that like that that that moment
that yo i got it i got it i got it
yeah yeah because this is this is this
is pre pandemic this is probably when
y'all in offices around each other and
you know um something can happen really
quickly
it's not like now something happens and
you gotta you know call and i got a zoom
meeting got a schedule is but now y'all
in the office you can hear somebody
screaming down the hall hey
but when we when we launched that it was
when we like made the official launch it
was during the pandemic oh
yeah yeah we were right launched on
browser it was there
yeah sounds about right that definitely
does sound about right yeah because i'm
remembering when we was in fan fest and
we got a chance to see this stuff that
was like pre-pandemic that was
pre-painted yeah we met we met we were
initially beta yeah cause you guys were
in beta shout out to the great bill
stilwell we went to e3
and at that point it was like i said it
was phone and you had a data center in
like san francisco or something or azure
and then it was like we were like wow
and we're playing and we're like yo
there's like no latency what like this
feels like halo 5 straight up like it
was pretty amazing so um so so that yeah
that's right it sounds about probably
when you guys launch powers pandemic
that's crazy so yeah you got that
another thing too i noticed that i want
to give the team a lot of credit for is
how like
basically what i feel you've done
doesn't get enough credit is how you've
leveraged next generation tech
on legacy devices so for example you
know
we right now we series x series s and
there's some next generation but then
like for example that's what let's be
real microsoft flight simulator is not
gonna run on the og xbox one like xbox
but like it was not designed for that so
like why was that so important to the
vision of x-cloud gosh like uh phil is
phil has basically stated like being
able to run and play legacy games and
have them stand on their own right right
just just people love to go back and
play their old-school games i do i mean
i i you know and just to be able to play
it on
on the systems i have like a you know
the series x you know go back and play
some of the old school games and vice
versa like if you have an xbox
one
you can play flights in
crazy right and it's and it's awesome
like flights them don't even run on most
computers
right right like the most epic thing
right now for fights and for me it's
like
my wife's uh
dad he's a big fight some fan yeah right
he played it on his previous computer
um but he had got a new computer and it
and the flight sim wasn't compatible
with it so he kept playing um and we and
i'm working on the new flight style for
cloud so i can't say anything but i'm
like just just just just just just like
you could
get the b just yet
i was like you know um because he was
thinking about trying to apply console
but you know i was like yeah if you buy
console you gotta go i was like just you
know we'll we'll work through it so i
never never brought about it back up and
i'll say hey guess what when we launched
a couple months ago i was like yes you
can do and he was like um plugged
controller in got him to play uh fight
some on i got a picture of it too i
haven't posted on online there but i was
going to going to do that but yeah he's
he's super happy that he's able to play
flights and
um and and things like that on his pc
you hear that people there's actually
people that actually really love flight
sim they act like it's not a real game
you'll play that overlapping but that is
huge fascinating yes it is yeah it is it
is you know it's very impressive like
you said just to be able to play like i
said on legacy tech and consoles that
you know maybe couldn't physically made
up a handle that from a hallway
perspective
let me expand yeah go for it
because my first thing soon as i got a
chance to you know play flight sim
the first thing i did was fly over the
projects i grew up in
and i was like oh sweat it really looked
like it
cloud tech and then next i went to egypt
where was the first place that you went
to uh um
what i did was um well on the new on the
new flight sim right it was fight some i
actually did i just did a flight to l.a
right so i just did from flew off from
seattle to l.a yeah and one of the crazy
things about how the high def like what
the the best thing one of the best
things about it is the visuals right so
you're flying and you remember all those
california wildfires yeah
they actually had that in the game like
you could see the the uh the fire
fire trail in the game i was like this
is amazing yeah yeah that's kind of this
is wow it is one of those moments where
you do realize it is i you know the the
term back then it was kind of funny
reacting like you know when people say
the power of the cloud i was kind of
running joke against y'all let's be real
but it's one of those games where it's
the perfect marriage of the technology
and you seeing it come to life right
you're like wow this is this could not
be possible right
without that type of tech in place and
it's pretty impressive so even hear you
say that i don't even realize that you
know from that standpoint with with the
uh with the map system and and real-time
weather effects and you know things
transitioning it's just extremely
impressive so i'm glad you mentioned
that what i did want to talk about was
um you know again so you talk about that
you talk about the launch you get that
out you're coming out on phones you're
doing that but like one thing i know
initially that i felt your competitor
did have over you at the time
was the full browser into integration as
far as like stadium like stadium came
out and i'm a techie so i had to try it
i had to see what was going on i'm like
man this is impressive you know and at
the time xcloud was limited just to
phone at the time so talk about now that
transition where now xbox game streaming
microsoft edge browser like how big was
that for the team
it was it was huge it was always part of
our strategy right
um so it was it was huge to see it and
then see the success of it like we're
seeing a lot of success from it so
um just giving people the opportunity to
play games through browser um you can
stream on your consoles
um through uh through through through
cloud gaming and it's just like you know
once we once once we launched that it
was like it just opened up
so many doors for people to be able to
play games and that's sort of just the
bottom line man i just want to play i
just want to work on i don't want to
work to give people
all the opportunity to play as many
games as they want to
anywhere they want to right now um phone
tablet
tv
wait for that tv refrigerator it doesn't
matter whatever you want whatever you
want to see people joke about the
refrigerator though but um actually
uh
the tvs on the refrigerator you can
actually play like little games
i think i think i saw on a video
somebody hooked up something and they
were able to play i think that's cloud
on there yeah for a fridge
i don't think people realize like how
important like i get it
us old-fashioned gamers when we hear
like streaming games we're just like oh
i don't want to do that now first off
like you might think that now
it's just like the thing like
10 years ago we had a completely
different mindset for digital only games
like you know sooner or later you're
going to start breaking those walls down
and i think people need to realize
that's happening sooner rather than
later i'm not gonna say it's gonna
happen like like next year but it's
gonna be a part where you know
cloud stream may not be one to one but
it's gonna be as close as you possibly
can get to it and it's just like look
like there's a lot of countries
in the world that don't even play
consoles like that like they they need
that mobile aspect to even have a foot
in those countries yeah no it's huge and
to see like i said like how things are
advancing how the tech is advancing is
pretty pretty impressive what i do want
to ask you too in reference to that was
you know azure is the huge backbone for
you guys right and and we know
you know i remember speaking to king and
we were like wow this is impressive and
these are like xbox one s server blades
or something he does that at the time
and then now we see that we hear the
jump you know xbox series i know me
personally that uses xcloud a lot like
i'm a person that i get excited like oh
the doctor's office how long is the way
oh okay cool driving oh
no probably you bust out the kishi and
i'm right i'm ready to go so i love it
you know say i i get excited for the way
so my question is like was the series x
server
blade upgrade you know was that
necessary also to facilitate more things
like that as far as like performance and
then you guys are also doing um
almost
you were playing the game you could play
the game natively like before you
download the the whole install like it
was was it series x was that part of it
getting those server blades to get more
functionality oh yeah yeah you know some
of these games and titles are really you
know
we want to provide the best performance
and and reduce latency so
um those are those are definitely things
that we want to do to make sure that
we're accomplishing those goals for the
players
just thinking through it you know we've
come a long way to get there um we're
not done yet
that's the cool thing about it so it's
like you know we're continuing to grow
and learn uh based off the game playing
based off the feedback that we get from
our gamers so we're taking all that
information in and then we're just like
so one one thing everybody i think
there's 556 people watching now hey if
you got feedback yes on xcloud or
anything xbox let's go please provide it
because if that that helps us solve
problems that helps us
um you may have an idea if you have an
idea about something throw it in there
don't don't how can they do that lord
paris like do they have to hold down the
xbox you can hold it all down to the
start yeah okay we hold it down and then
we hit report that's how we do it yeah
yeah yeah there you go okay i just want
to make sure some people ain't clear
because i'm just for the record i'm like
lead leader in achievements on the
inside of program that's me i'm the guy
the top of everybody's scoreboard
[Music]
hold the start button
yes report problem y'all you already
know what it is
give us your feedback you know i mean
you know give us some actionable
feedback
well when i get to this sucks i'm like
so what sucks
is the truth
like the latency sucks
there we go okay
okay exactly and then with that
information you would be able to pull
where they may be where they're from and
what type of environment they're wrong
i'm trying to figure out what's going on
if it's a game problem if you know if
there's an actual bug if there's you
know server problems there's cool that
must have been a really hard choice
in uh upgrading the server blades
knowing that that stock is going to come
away from the actual initial point it's
going to reach the crowd
um and in order to you know to take that
initial hit that an issue bump but you
know the benefits down the line is going
to benefit everybody as a whole
um that that takes a lot of foresight
and fortitude to stay tall in that in
that position and it's starting to show
benefits now because you might be close
i don't know
to uh finishing up all the server blades
and some stock is actually being
available in stores now where people i
get people hitting me up daily you know
they didn't in the store man i see one
in the store
[Laughter]
they're in the stores now they're
they're out there right now
yeah
you can you can get them they're uh the
series x's are out there right now so no
doubt no doubt i got two people local
retailers for sure check them out got a
few more questions let me wrap up with
this section um definitely want to talk
about steam deck you know it's kind of
like the hottest
thing right now you know shout out to
gabe newton
i've seen that yeah yeah yeah
brother
i i hear your throat so i hear you got
to throw a problem i'ma speak for you so
so um yeah like what was pretty cool is
just to see gabe shout out to gabe noble
oh no talk about it and then i'll see
you know phil
talking about you know wanting to work
together right and wanting to try to get
x cloud streaming and game game
streaming on the device and obviously
there's a document right now on on xbox
as far as how to implement a shout out
but man dj oros who's in the chat he has
the steam man i'm not fortunate to
haven't steamed that yet but i asked him
like how i canceled
i saw what was going on i was just
saying i chill for a second i'll wait
until microsoft actually is you know
integrated inside well they definitely
they definitely have an integration
piece now right from an infancy stage
and he was telling me like he's like oh
no once you set this thing up he was
like it is really impressive so i just
wanted to know you know as far as having
edge on it you know just your thoughts
there briefly and um you know is i guess
my question to you is is the work still
ongoing is it or is something you know
we could kind of just take for it for
what it is now i would just say that um
we're always looking to partner with you
know
you know folks out there that are
delivering great things in gaming you
know we do want to continue we want to
be able to give people the ability to
play the games they want to play
anywhere they want to play
and if there's a browser
we want to be able to enable you for
that so
okay oh okay you can use safari you can
use the edge you can use properly that
is true all the all the main browsers
out there you can use and and and sign
in and get into play games i mean you
could see
and they'll be the show 22. funny thing
is when you launch that you see sony
interactive
so you know what i i love him
here we go that was a little messy here
we go
see i didn't bring it up today you just
you just oh you just empowered paris
i did download it
i'm gonna get a chance to play some
baseball but i do appreciate somebody
else appreciating what i appreciate when
i when i press go
loving that sony playstation game
studios i appreciate it yes
honey we know his pedigree he was out
there in japan when it was happening so
we know what's better we can parents
i mean uh the funny thing is that uh
when you see that sony interactive
studios when you launch the show
i launched it in the cloud i launched it
you know i haven't downloaded yet i just
play it on i'm playing an x-clap right
so if you're a game pass subscriber you
can play
uh
that's that's an incredible baseball
game
the home run derby is awesome yes that's
right that's right you can experience
that in the cloud today
you can experience that in the cloud
today yes today live yes day date we
understand cloud
power cloud
okay we got other questions but we got
another question we got we got it that
wasn't me
in the cloud right and uh
from a skeptic perspective because
there's still a lot of people that were
like look man that that cloud streaming
man you know
i'm not you know how guys are like you
know a lot of gamers
don't listen to me you know gamers are
resistant to change you know what i'm
saying like i don't believe in it you
know i'm never going to play my games
like that and you know from
i just wanted to ask paris you know how
difficult the challenge is to kind of
innovate a future that technically one
does not exist right then you got two
gamers who are so like extremely
skeptical and i speak for myself like
i'm i'm a person who had netflix back in
the day when they used to mail you the
disk
right remember i mean yeah
you get the disk right right and now
look at me right there's you know it's
all so like you know what do you think
needs to happen you know can you talk
about that pm background the vision well
i mean yeah yeah if you think about it
if you think about the vision and
strategy like
cloud gaming may not be for everybody
right and that's and that's a fact right
people in the united states are more
affluent
than people other people across the
globe it's just a fact right you have a
lot of people that have the ability to
get consoles and they're used to a
certain speed and certain graphic
content and all that other stuff right
but they're not putting themselves in
the shoes of someone that can't afford a
console
and um and things like that in a country
where the tariffs are maybe too high for
them to buy one yes right um and
how do they get to be able to play games
um if they have a good internet
connection and they can't afford a
console what's another way for them to
play games the cloud right
um and that's maybe the only way they
can they can experience you know some
people don't even there's probably
there's a lot of places in this in the
world today they may not even have cell
phones right still right just imagine
like
just growing up knowing that you don't
like there's people out there that don't
have a cell phone good point like he's
like the cell phone is like the basic
needs for people you better communicate
better talk there's people in the world
that don't even have that opportunity
right there's people that have cell
phones and have you know steady internet
they don't have the money to buy
consoles
um you know and things like that and
their infrastructure may be to the point
in the in the world where it's good
enough to do cloud gaming right
so that's
the perspective that i look at it from
that's like you know if somebody's out
there talking negative about it i'm like
okay well i mean
go to a country where you don't have a
console yep and play games
how are you going to play them you're in
the playing through steam you're going
to play them
hopefully through xcloud right so those
are the things that we want to be able
to provide gamers to be able to play um
across the globe this isn't just about
the united states this is about the
world exactly
i think the issue of
everybody together i think the issues a
lot of people just closed-minded when it
comes to situations that doesn't that
doesn't revolve around them right so
like you know it's like i said there
there's certain
countries sure they they can have a
council there and they sell consoles
there but the culture has moved away
from consoles
and i don't think people think the
american culture is everywhere it's not
like no it's a good point it's a good
point but what what lapras said that i
really appreciate was that you know
one thing i like as far as your guys
approach is it's not okay we're gonna
lock it you into this is the only way
you can game
right and what's cool is it's an option
you've always stressed that it's been an
option i think the mistake your
competitors have made would say no this
is it this is only you doing this and
also it combined with that then you have
this amazing service and game pass right
that so it's like you got this amazing
library for just being a part of it you
know what i mean kind of thing and i
think that approach is cool the question
i do i did want to ask those from from a
future thinking standpoint though like
is it do you think it's what from from a
map more adoption rate do you think it
like does 5g need to hit do you think
you know maybe tv usb stick like what
the app on the tv more server forms or a
combination of all these things for you
yeah
i would say a combination of all those
things need to happen to for us to be
able to reach the gamers that we want to
reach right so
um as as i don't know if people part uh
or look at what's going on in the world
like
um you look at
infrastructures and like in south
america and what they're doing to get to
5g right um we're paying attention to
that separate stuff right those are the
things that we have to to watch out for
because as
countries invest in their infrastructure
they're building for 5g to get people to
be able to communicate with others
across the across the country across
their country right um and we're looking
forward to that because that basically
enables us to be able to come in and say
hey guess what you can play xcloud there
too
so so yeah all that stuff is in
conjunction of us reaching those gamers
um you
know partnerships through um uh telcos
and stuff like that um you got the sk
you got the sk telecom one i believe
that was huge and on the device level i
remember the samsung seeing that kind of
yeah
lg
yeah there's a lot of partnerships in
place yeah so you've seen some of those
things that we've been able fortunate
enough to be able to do
um as countries build their
infrastructures and as we uh uh able to
improve what we there's a lot of work we
still need to do right we need to
improve our latency we need to improve
how fast the games are we need to be
able to get more titles into
into the cloud right please get tekken
back i miss it
what i've noticed
is the fact that two two pluses that's
in your favor
the fact that there's no additional cost
that goes inside game pass and is
included inside game pass and um i think
that's that's huge because a lot of
other companies uh charge for this
actual service this is some company's
actual whole model is revolved around
this service that is actually inside
game pass which is it's a boon and it's
a plus right the second thing that i
noticed is the fact that you can launch
the game
before the download and if you actually
like the game while you're playing it
you can download it in the background to
start playing it natively on the console
and that part right there saves so much
memory saves so much time it saves a a
lot of um
you know like installing
hard drive spaces
it's at a premium and you guys have
definitely nailed that in that aspect
and i love that i love to see
the little cloud uh icon next to the
install
when you go to the store and the thing
the thing too is you know i really
appreciate
i gotta be honest like it it's rare to
see how willing you guys are able to
work with other game companies right
like we said we talked about the steam
deck either and then you know i got a
quote great phil you know dominance no
dominus max maximum is spencer correct
let me let me let me say it right before
if he's watching this
he would appreciate it oh no doubt no
doubt he he knows i i have affection
yeah of course let's love he's always
loved but one thing he said that i
always appreciate was kind of like you
know the famous statement king which is
like
places where game pass exists right well
you know if you're willing you know they
are willing to work so you know we got
it we got some nintendo switches out
there and some other devices i'm just
saying you know i mean i mean lord
lockheed i'm just saying you know
where game pass exists if they're
willing to exist then you'll be willing
to bring your classroom over there so
providing us that feedback and we will
no
doubt you don't say if speaking of a
field okay okay yeah i was gonna say
king there was one thing you were
talking about as far as like the the uh
the ability to play games before you
download them yeah like like there's
there's there was times like where
people wouldn't play indie titles right
yeah because you got a 10 gig download
you're out of space i'm not going to
download this three gigs and then
uninstall it you know because i need it
for my big games right yep but now i can
go in and play indie titles and just run
through them and yeah
right i i play more indie towns than i
have ever on xcloud yeah than i ever
have in my life yes right games i never
had even really even thought of playing
but i probably would have been curious
about them but i just was like oh no i
don't have space or whatever but now i
have the cloud i've i've ran through
cloud games and beat them start to
finish
easy and i think the monument downloads
yes i think the marketing behind that
whole thought process is genius yeah
shout out to greenie and the team um
when when you put
uh find your next best game yes
that
offers the ability to just just we we
call it a buffet
so you know when you're on that buffet
line you may not ever wanted to spend
money on but you're like i'm here
i might get this crab cakes let me try
that you know
the ability to try
and and just keep going i i find your
next great game i thought that was
absolutely genius because i actually go
inside game pass and i look for like
wild west
never thought yeah yeah
and i'm like this is hot all right shout
out to acg oh you're going wild
we're going crazy over here
pa window central in there we see a lot
of people in this show
to lord paris lockhart
his video on wild west and i didn't know
it was in game pass then i saw it i was
like oh snap and i tried it i was like
yeah he's spot on as always but it's
this ability to try these games i've
never played this much games in my life
and i'm a true gamer from the beginning
you guys are doing something phenomenal
there yeah and and you i'm glad that
we're able to give you your roses today
in that regard because it's
from the inception of it it was a lot of
skepticism with it
but every day i'm pretty sure that you
turn people into believers which is
incredible by tearing down barriers of
entry and that's great absolutely it's
it's my community man it's by having you
know people like your like yourselves
going out there and spreading the word
and and um also just playing games with
folks and giving you know sharing the
fact that hey we can all be a community
and yeah and play and accomplish these
uh these titles that we never even would
have thought of playing before because
we just didn't have space or something
like that i think
yeah i think when it comes to the
community in general
people forget why we're here in the
first place you know what i'm saying
like it's like if you don't like
something if you like something it's
like it's all about the games
like in the center it's the games yeah
no it's always about the games and like
you said the mission
getting games on the device you want
where you want to play it how you want
to play it and the includes the
inclusivity of it right that that's what
makes it really cool there's no the
entries they're bringing down the
barriers to entry and you look you'd
love to see it so yeah so look at you
guys on that it's been fantastic two
quick fun questions that we wrap up
because this is i didn't know we had
this much fun so i apologize on the top
i kind of did yeah i didn't realize what
it looked like
yeah this is gonna be an episode i
already know but um
fun questions um so since your passion
for destiny is very strong like the
lords
i need to know because i see y'all play
very often
oh god
into destiny first you all lord phil
dominance max what's your favorite
yes i need to know this um
i think we
we've probably been playing at the same
time so he had started destiny 1 and i
was playing destiny one but we never
really played together right right
destiny won and then at the end of
destiny one we started playing and then
we
hooked up
um i was before i even joined xbox what
i was doing
um so i used to run our our our internal
meetings like
like teams and stuff like that teams
yeah yeah yeah
i own like all our conference room
spaces like over 20 000 conference rooms
wow wow and i remember being in a board
room and i was uh just setting up making
sure everything was good to go for this
big meeting if phil was in there he was
like yeah you should come play with me
and i was like man stop playing with me
he said you you just talking
all right okay so uh i just hooked up
with them and then we started playing
and then it just sort of just carried on
and we played like all the time on
destinations oh that's dope that's great
they've run around
together too we've been doing the
teamwork on elder rings nice
yeah yeah we that's why i was asking
because we we got we got invaded the
only thing about others about that it's
like if you get invaded and the main
person dies everybody goes back to their
home oh yeah shout out to that yeah
that's just that we got to protect the
football that's that's that's literally
what it is the moment people invade i
will literally tell king of like stunned
he told me
see i got these little things that i do
so attic says and we notice because at
first i really didn't understand i'm
like you've been invaded then i see the
red dude and i said oh
absolutely
i thought the red dude was the blood
stain that i clicked
that is hilarious he said but he's
coming after me though
right next to his blood stain
like i said paris you need help on that
oh that destiny you gotta rock with the
lord you gotta ride with the lawyers we
gotta get you through a raid
you gotta get it through the raid
absolutely i love the fact that you guys
are actual gamers you play the games we
see you guys rocking so cool finally i
swear because it's so much fun um i
gotta highlight the last day you know
your love for marvel you know in the
cinematic universe and and you know you
kind of come from our era which is like
the era of the the gi joes the
transformers outside the marvel comic
books you go to the store you buy the
book you know you ain't king kind of
confident so my question like you know
you literally run one of the most
enormous
facebook groups
but um you know over there and it's
called what is the marvel cinematic
universe right yeah marvel cinematic
universe uh private facebook group we're
the largest on facebook for group wise
right we're not just a page where people
just don't know why we're a group a
community of folks that uh talk about uh
all things marvel movies
uh games toys
it's amazing very positive community
respectful of the passion actors in
there from this i got i got to check
this
we ain't going to just gloss over to
what actors
might be in there
well
i've been working on that but when you
get them in there it's changing the
dynamics oh y'all better get in the
group y'all
mark greg is in there so you can look
clear he's in there there's a few other
actors in there some producers some
people from the back end of marvel
studios and stuff like that so uh disney
and uh aiming all that stuff so it's
just uh it's a great community that i
know they say
did you just did you just gloss over amy
pascal in there
oh no no
shooting this shot with xbox get in the
marvel game we're gonna get to these
super chats we're gonna get through
i know i know trust me i want my hashtag
just one too you know i want that hey
you know what i've been dying for him
all again too yeah
i'm so i'm you're not the only one oh
okay though you fighting a good fight in
the building no i'm trying that good
fight i don't know if anybody i don't
know if my boss is watching i know if
she's watching but catherine let's try
to get him yeah
catherine like katherine if you listen
you know i'm i'm the leader of the
hashtag just one movement and i feel
that you know it would be awesome if
xbox had a superhero game third party
cinematic experience type game that you
know whether it be black panther i'm
that's your business let me finish
just one marvel cinematic game
third person narrative
it's going to sell like hot cakes and if
it's a game pass it's over continue
[Laughter]
okay
okay i don't want to mcu
um marvel game okay i want uh a marvel
game okay oh oh okay okay okay
there's a reason behind it right um
i want a uh
uh authentic comic book game okay
opposed to a mcu game there's two
distinct differences
you know um because one is uh
you know the ultimate universe slash the
616 universe merged in to give you
something that's palatable for the uh
for the viewer me personally i just want
the organicness of it so if you're gonna
give me a ghost rider game i wanted
johnny blaze
in the studio right now
you're playing during the night so in
the daytime
you're fighting you're fighting the
humans that are protecting the vampires
nighttime you're finding the vampires
you got to go into different hideouts
then you've got to be able to get the
serums and make sure you like turn it
into players
i got
i got something else man i got something
else what you got you sprinkle the
nemesis engine in there and the vampires
have arch lords and stuff okay
so he's been trying to get the
nervousness engine and everything yeah i
love it though
because it's only like two games it's a
great engine
this is the biggest thing the biggest
thing
whose face is on it is it wesley snipes
face
oh is it
yeah
well he he didn't get a chance to do it
yeah we're not even going to include him
he got to get his movie out the door
okay
yeah
it's got to be wesley but if it's done
in the future it has to be the other one
yeah usually what's your dick pack
what'd you do
i'm thinking um i'm thinking marshall
ellie yeah and i know i know that you
know wesley snipes he's the one who did
a lot of good oh geez
right oh gee but if you were to like if
you just say hey we're going to take a
computer animated version though yeah
yeah
and then throw it on a cover then i
would say just mix it between both of
them gotcha or they'll have different
skins sell the dlc there you go there
you go
there you go nice salute to you man we
love them we love the passion for volvo
this is dope um can't wait to see what
you guys do there and again love what
you're doing on the cloud streaming side
and how the tech improves keep doing
what you're doing brother the final
thing that we asked every guest you know
say we got to put it i need lord
lockheed's top five video games or
franchises of all
time all time
i don't have to be in order either not
to be in order okay well i'm going to
say destiny because you know i've been
rocking listen man you hear that flame
then i would have to say um uh
definitely halo yes okay it was on that
list that's one guy that's two bungie's
titles
actually not really three four three is
down there three yeah
calm because i was addicted to this
that was great for me
yeah oh my gosh yeah part two was nuts
yeah um
uh
with one on four yeah we are number
three we gotta that's three we need
number four now um madden cause i just
been playing i haven't seen
respect forever yeah
my last matter was the truck stick
i like to hit it with the boom
[Music]
yeah i think i stopped playing madden
madden
19 was like
i need to i know i probably need to jump
back in it just started getting to i
just just my my game back well it's in
game pass you can do it any time
[Laughter]
and um
man is it 2k or if it's nba live man
i mean 2k took it to the next level
though uk took it to
dreamcast which was crazy on that show
but we could do it no he wasn't there he
wasn't part of that that's cool that
wasn't part of my uh he was in the
arcades he's got people up there
yeah you guys have the benefits to get
the
out
consoles
playing them
what's that last one
last one this can always evolve and
change later yeah now let's get all this
involved and check i would just say half
live 2k okay okay okay
basketball basketball
salute to that and then the bonus round
that one had the nos intro right i think
so i can't remember
i just posted it though
now the the bonus
will be for you
i need more lucky's top five mcu movies
of all
that's good oh
[Music]
leading the witness to say top five says
something he tries to direct something
right
you are king of leading the witnesses
yeah he tried to shut down a preemptive
strike for what i normally do but i have
not led the witness yes
[Laughter]
so
mcu um mcu let's go um
infinity war is number one okay
i can respect that
i wasn't
yes
it was a good movie it was actually a
great movie broke all the records
money-wise you've got to keep it and
there's a lot of stuff stories finished
the surprise in the end yes captain
america on your left
thor's fat
fat thorn
the whole thing was uh was pretty good
okay um uh well that's three um
i would say black panther oh uh
touch the soul um and then
um
yeah man five is tough because there's
just i have i like them all like there's
just
for your personality
there's no age of ultron on it yeah
exactly and you know what i'm gonna put
cognito in the bushes
it's bad it's a bed of culture
and i know he's gonna respect this the
only reason why adrian ultron is up
there because one it gave you everybody
gave you ulysses claw introduced you to
wakanda gave you the vision gave you
scarlet witch
let's not act like these things didn't
happen and it gave you the reason why
everybody was going after everybody
inside the winter soldier so without
this movie none of those movies happen
but again i'm going to sit back here and
relax
[Laughter]
remember um ultron is the one in what is
no i'm just saying with that mentality
i do actually put iron man very high
because everything was wrong up out of
here
yeah for sure for sure and last this
this one is actually going to be
interesting basically which is
favorite
console i think i know it based on your
history this could be surprising so
let's see favorite console volunteering
and why history and why series x
wow you know what i respect that okay
tell us why though tell us why tell us
why um
everything expansion card the
ability to the fat how fast it is
jason ronald approves of this jason
comes around often
completely produces home team but but
but tell us like i get i get the system
design is glorious we also got a shout
out to the little band the series s
a fantastic complimentary console got my
x green on it it's it's beautiful but
like
i know
let's get to is it
because you're behind the scene and you
know what's coming
from a game perspective because you
started off strong you started list this
is a strong start for you guys great
generation arguably setting i've told
people i'm probably a peter moore 360
era kind of guy but i will say the
series x's start right now from an xbox
console perspective it is on its way and
the moves you guys are making obviously
the bethesda you know the xbox game
studios and then obviously the soon to
be potentially activision like it it is
looking like this could be one of those
generations is it that for you and
because you're in in the building and
you know what's coming
um
as a i'm not gonna go as a just a gaming
fan perspective okay let's go like i
remove myself from knowing what's coming
and what we're working on but as a
gaming fan perspective of i'm a fan of
you know games
and just having the ability to do what
uh xbox is offering like i would
definitely sign up for it i would be a
game pass subscriber
i would be playing x-car i would be on
all these things and just the series x
itself just the the box itself the power
that it that it generates and just being
able to
play the games at the speed that it's
doing right yeah i'm playing no no not
skins playstation 5 they're it's doing
this thing too but i just for me
my perspective as a fan uh
this is what i would prefer no doubt
shot and you know and just the moves
that xbox is making and and things like
that
soon to be something potentially big
just
all the other titles that that were
announced and that are uh to be uh to be
seen
to be announced to be announced
all right shout out shout out to the hd
grown women gamer she said you're doing
a fantastic job oh yeah she said she
said you're doing fantastic right now
you're doing it you're amazing right now
i mean so no you got me excited you got
me excited for what's coming there's
there's no doubt about it salute lord
paris lockhart aka lord lockheed in the
realm appreciates you staying as long as
you're getting again we're not kicking
out but i know if you have to do things
you have to do things but man i'm good
i'm still rocking i
i just want to point out so you sure
you're like we got just two times it'll
be quick it's the demo in the driveway
yeah but we do we do got to read the
super chat so the super chats came
extreme yeah i think you should make the
super chat right let's do the super
hit the like button frauds we got a two
dollar super chat from havoc kong foo on
nes was best we got a two dollar super
chat from uh solo gaming um
lives got ruined by arch rivals oh yeah
that's the one where you can fight
double dribble with with fighting yeah
much rivals we got a five dollar street
from hollywood uh y'all took me back
with a double dribble corner three in
genesis spiderman
excellent iop sunday king looking
forward to the fight show
from havoc i remember being in japan and
playing the uh the flight fighter sim
that had a chair rotate like a like a
real plane that's what i'm talking about
that's what i was asking because they
had it but we never had it here and that
thing was huge though it cost like more
than thirty thousand dollars i think was
like fifty thousand dollars that whole
setup it was crazy no doubt
got that we got a
a five dollar a two dollar screwdriver
from havoc bro that's all he said bro
yeah cause he was out in japan yeah he
was outside from for uh for boy gaming
someone made me a moderator we got a
five dollar super chat from 105
uh
oh 108
brother xcloud has made king proud
day and date part of what we already
have played uh where anywhere
oh my god this is real gaming shout out
to the pedal game passes life
we gotta find out subscribe from uh from
hindu shane
or whatever man you know i don't care
you're good
sony we put uh we can't put our games
day and day in in uh subscription except
is it in game pass then it totally works
okay uh we got a hundred dollar super
trap from acg oh my gosh
with his arm's backs looks so
comfortable when i clicked on this keep
it up iron
we got another hundred dollars to
project from acg let's get this super
chat train going awesome we got a five
dollars
super chat from zgl7
king those 50 cent headphones are dope
i've got a pair as well
[Music]
uh then we got a
hold up let me okay
then we got a 20 picture from paris lock
is
[Laughter]
i truly love this show uh shout out to
the panel
of two dollars from jonas
well xbox oh you already had the xbox
ever get a marvel look man this isn't
ask the dude questions he can't answer
this is my thing with the chat why you
always want to ask people questions you
know they can't answer we gotta choose
super cat from splint man stop it y'all
we need that spawn game fan come on
is that really what you want oh damn
think about it mm-hmm
we got to fight out stripper from gj
warriors destiny back to game pass
sounds like a good idea throw them
online for game pass and pc
so hey besties
i'm pretty sure i'm pretty sure sony has
something to say about that uh destiny
go in the game
we gotta find out super traffic shiny
phil dominus and say needs to buy warner
discovery to get the video content as
well as the game studios and now you
have superhero games no doubt and then
we got another two dollar super episode
um cog was dipping in his hand all in my
bet man bag time cog
i don't know what's going on
uh
i i can't see his whole name okay you
cannot defeat my
five dollar super chat i don't even know
if i want to read the rest of that let's
go but you can keep the mcu give me an
xbox exclusive the boys are invincible
style game next to knock these heroes
down a peg or two that would be good
i don't know if that's the one you want
to come out the gate with
yeah boys invincible is a great show go
watch it yeah they're great
artistic takes on stuff
what else
i'm looking okay
doing a good job sir
i read that one
you're doing way better read that one
let me read the ones i do see when it
comes to the members chat because i
can't see them rock star could do a boys
that would be cool rockstar don't want
to do anything but gta unfortunately
dragonheart yobe
for five months from rail we need
destiny 2 back in game pass oh there you
go is she for the streets
[Laughter]
we got a 10 months
member from dragon heart yobe tv
legendary lords keep up the great work
proud of y'all uh hashtag peace love
life y'all legends and i am extremely
proud i talk from the heart when i say
this y'all deserve a round
thank you much love much love
oh god oh god we got a
got a two dollar super chat from oh man
they're coming soon
we got a ten dollar street drive from
noby
series x plays no we sidebar series x
plays all the best games across every
generation of course it's his favorite
system
two dollar super chat from gamer by
choice nina need an x uh a need and
marvel ultimate or blue marvel game
i'll take some more ultimate alliance i
think it's very hard to do a superman
type of game because no but did you see
what they did with it we're going to
talk about the internet engine
yeah we're going to talk about that
all right so i got it dropped from one
yo addict out here rita's super chest
like that liberal mutual actor
commercial that don't know his uh his i
say that like come on son his damn life
look this isn't my job okay i'm pitching
in yeah he's helping relax with the way
two weeks it is remember two weeks today
not discouraging we got two weeks of
this yes
king gonna come in next week don't raise
the super chat no he will not because
king got on shades and king king wear
glasses so no doubt the only time you
see kennywood super chat
time time let's move on
we got we got a uh a 16 month uh message
from mexican zogerberg
philly d invited paris over to his show
what the d in his name stands for
spoiler alert it's not dom pause moving
on you're left with it
moving on
to stop my uh man's bag his hand not
allowed i don't know what's going on
moving on we're not doing that 11
members super chat uh from black road in
great show as always i'd love to see a
first
party spawn incredible blue marvel storm
or luke cage game on gamepad's day one
all right guys thank god good job we're
shutting them down shut them down to the
next okay cool so we got that we got the
pole you did it once you did it
anyway last people results are in the
people have spoken to the question with
the latest revamp of playstation plus as
it currently stands do you view this as
a viable competitor to xbox game pass
the winner at 63 percent of the vote was
no without first party playstation
studio day date and date or or more
non-streaming options for legacy titles
it's a lesser service group coming in at
second place at 31 percent of the vote
was the messi lords i don't care we
revolt if vita is not added to the
service and in last place with only four
percent of the vote was yes multiple
generations of playstation game
libraries and back compat will evolve
and share volume of title shout out to
the lords who participate in the poll
lord king the realm agrees with you at
game passes the superior service right
now
well i mean
it it's it shows that i mean the rumor
agrees to like the internet at this
point like
you know i am the internet so therefore
i will answer this he didn't ask you
all right you got to make this all about
that's all about him you know how you do
that
you're good
i just gave you big up now leave me
alone
the fact that i told you guys uh quality
can be found inside a gaming uh
service uh as to metacritic's 12-year
break that microsoft did in bitcoin
becoming uh the publisher of the year
with uh fantastic titles inside game
pass i say
quality can be found stop making excuses
and just let's get down if you really
want to fight
put up the dukes baby
okay we see what you're doing moving on
let me get a couple super chats real
quick cause my man shout out i wouldn't
be remiss if i don't shout out italian
clowns follow super chat king is always
right or hail the king all hail the king
shout out this is why his ego is the way
it is
yeah this is a stroke yeah
shout out to lucious augustus the homie
from the discord you remember for eight
months they really while into the super
chat shout out to you attic he gave
attic his props he said then the angry
therapist md telling us to chat that og
spider-man game was the most comic book
accurate spider-man if you didn't take
pictures for jameson you wouldn't you
couldn't make web fluid and yes venom
was idiot and you're smiling
go off my angry therapist i remember it
was a great game man salute you already
know shout out to flame for being
mentioned so let's get into it so first
topic up hello man halo um season two
lone wolves announced we saw the trailer
you know what's going on so it's finally
some content looks like it will have it
actually still actually story they show
two spartans kind of with the lone
wolves theme we got some season maps
there will be a new map called catalyst
and new big team battle map named
breaker which was also featured in the
trailer is going to be some uh new modes
potentially last spartan standing an ffa
elimination mode and a new mode called
land grab
king of the whole kick of the hill is
also returning and has been updated
there's been a lengthy blog post by 343
and to their credit you know they chimed
in on a lot of the customization and a
lot of feedback that let's be honest a
lot of people upset with the with the
level of content coming in so let's
start with lord lucky paris lockhart um
how excited are you
for season two lone wolves
um as someone that's been starving from
content yes i'm glad you said it because
i was gonna say it
love you i'm excited for it yeah um i i
know just just being on the back end
there's a lot of work they've been
they've been super busy
i'm trying to get all the stuff together
um you know launching without you know
co-op you know that was you know
it was what it is but i think that uh
the content is coming um
and i think this this lone wolves is
gonna you know get the fans hyped again
and i think uh
i just can't wait to get a chance to
play it
having opportunities being on inside
where people are like hey you can try
things out i didn't do any of that i
want to play when they launch okay i can
experience it from the as a fan would
there's some titles that i do that on so
let's just
yeah i can't wait for this i have way
more restraint than i could ever yeah
that's way too much restraint brother
like i need to know what's going on i
need to be what is it show me your bill
show me your build 343.
people have been tagging me all day on
addict where's your bill yeah that's
that's the new thing addict made a
statement we gotta get emojis yeah oh
you said you know about it
we're so excited but uh salute to you
for for handling it kind of just like
from a fair perspective consuming it
when the fans you know consume it so all
right it's fair not fair enough lord
addict man any of this excites you or is
it too little too late for you you need
to see more well it's not too little too
late like look i've always been in the
mindset like look
you could feel away about the lack of
content i feel way about the lack of
concept but you know what else i feel
away about the lack of content when i
gotta wait six months for anything where
i live it in destiny when i got away
with six rounds for anything relevant in
any type of game i played like look i
will say that maybe the game should have
been delayed to at least incorporate
co-op yeah but it wasn't so we're not
we're not doing like a
a a a different realm of a future it
wasn't we got to deal with it
yeah so it's just like at this point my
only issue with halo is the tv show
oh you don't like the tv show oh lock
don't do it
so like when it comes to this i like the
lone wolf idea like look is it enough to
bring everyone back
that's debatable this just depends what
content they give us depends on how much
they promote that content and what they
do with that content i personally feel
like one of the only thing that's going
to get the masses back and sure you can
get people back in but the masses i feel
like is going to require like a
substantial
single player story content with a
multiplayer season which that's just me
we're gonna have to see exactly how it
goes and how they how they launched the
promotion i there's some rumor going
around about some battle royale mode so
you know uh depends on how they do that
you know they i think i have every
confident that they can get the people
back that's not playing anymore because
it's just like destiny it's like it's
like every other types of games as a
service thing you can get the people
back people go out and they'll say some
crazy stuff about not playing a game
that's a good
point it says some crazy stuff about
destiny my asphalt witch queen so yeah
no no it it it's a good point in as far
as you know look we're not gonna gloss
over you know what we felt was you know
some some missteps from a content
perspective at launch but to your point
the nature of live service if you do
what your community wants you to do and
it launches on time in his life
people can't people can't come so that
is a good point let's get lloyd king in
halo infinite lone wolves a little some
story content too you know yeah well um
[Music]
i predicted all of that shout out to my
97 percent of being always right um
[Music]
go talk your time
on twitter and you claim it is yours and
listen listen i said it you was on the
show when i said they gonna launch with
uh story content and i said um the
battle royale thing i said a lot of
stuff he did say he you were the first
to say about the um the infinite being
truly infinite like a live server you
did say that it's going to continue to
be i thought the name rang exactly how
they they wanted it to i think they
leading heavily into their marketing now
as far as the content coming i i have to
blame it on the pandemic i don't care
what anybody says y'all could say
whatever you have to fight me if you
like but i truly believe that that had a
lot to do with things um watching the tv
show that i love and my wife loves so
much because she's not a fan of halo she
has absolutely no idea what halo is but
that tv show is incredible to her so she
actually loves the tv show and she
thinks it's dope so um
i saw a lot of lone wolf things and
themes inside the tv show and i was like
and i'm curious to think did that
actually lean into it did that have
something to do with this dlc
to your point they did say that they are
planning some type of incorporation with
tv show things oh god i'm curious if
it's going to be
masculine chief but that's another story
you know what they're skinned you know
what i don't i don't because i don't
think it works in that meeting i just
think it works in this medium
and you have to see the range of emotion
from the character i understand it now
um i don't agree with it at most points
and i'm i'm with attic in that in that
regard but um when you know like he's
sitting around in the house with his
with his face out
can i get dressed something real quick
in the chat because we keep like
mentioning like how i'm sitting i don't
have my normal chair this chair is like
kind of messed up yeah so i'm leaning
back because i can't look it's a
four-hour show most of the time i can't
do this for four hours
and this chair gives in too much so i'm
working on his space i can't sit how i
am
honestly we gotta get him the joint i
got from dj someone said why is he doing
the all-nighter constantly
i think
i i like it i like the idea of it um i
definitely would love a battle royale
and halo i think it would lean to it i
think the game needs to evolve in that
area we have the competitive version of
it as far as the multiplayer goes we
have oddball back uh king of the hill
thank god it's coming back i like that
um that mode let's let's let's get into
a battle royale mode where it actually
works for us i think that's dope um
i can't wait to try some of the new
stuff yeah and any content for halo is
definitely great content for me so
oh splendiferous had words for you
addict you might need to check the chat
oh but
anyway yeah look i'll jump in um yeah
like i think it's a start you know
obviously i've been very hard i'm not
even gonna sugarcoat just because lord
paris in the round you know what i'm
saying it's a bad pause for me yes i'm
very hard on the game technically
so look you know i'm not going to
sugarcoat it i definitely felt i would
have preferred it would have launched
and then held back with all the stuff
the co-op and stuff that i want it is
like alex said though it is what it is
this is where we are there right we are
outside we outside though it is i mean
we we we've asked what six months passed
almost yeah it is just to keep saying
what it should have launched right
it is what it is all i'm saying now is
you know for me this kind of reminds me
of like
house of wolves like this is the start
i'm not saying like this is everything
and this is going to
so much interest but it's a great start
okay there's content coming this map's
coming there's a new theme coming i love
that they're taking all the feedback my
main thing is to suit the customizations
i hate that i'm locked into a kit i want
to have that specific you know
customization gun here that prices on
the store and the main thing is the main
issues the de-syncing and a lot of the
experience issues that i know that they
said they are working on because you got
to make the core experience
better first right but i will say this
this to me sounds like a a prelude a
setup like even on a destiny standpoint
before taking king came out there was
like a you get to warm up whatever it
was right so
i think they were in the precipice if
they could get that going knock out the
core issues and then come with that next
one that's like boom well here's forge
here's co-op is and then now you're
really cooking and more maps and stuff
like that then i think you could you
know turn this thing around but um look
i'm excited of course you know new
content i'm gonna be in there i'm gonna
see what's going on shout out the little
lockey you know we got a couple of games
of halo infinite in the beginning launch
big team battle we had a bunch of fun
you know what i'm saying one of the
greatest comebacks i think we did
together which was kind of cool you know
so it looks the core gameplay is always
fun it's that's the weird thing about
this the game is fun the game is amazing
it's just we need content and it's good
to see content is coming yeah because
that that's the biggest issue it's like
i've always said halo can come back just
off the standpoint
that the issue that can be fixed isn't
isn't the issue right because when you
have the when you mess up the foundation
yes you're you're lost at that point but
that's not the issue
the issue is the content yeah people do
want they keep tagging send me messages
they want us to talk about this this
family plan room or tear thing that's
surfacing on their uh the twitter right
now
uh so pears can you you definitely don't
have to yeah
yes no but they they they do want us to
talk about these two no we could
apparently yeah well that's right no i
thought you said we weren't going to
talk about it but yeah apparently
there's like an entire like tier list
that's been leaked on the internet okay
uh so if you guys want to we could talk
about that after the last topic yeah
that's fine but um yeah so that's pretty
much what i had on um on halo like i
said we'll see what happens coming up
soon so uh lord king your topic is next
actually before we transition i want to
get there was only one super chat game
so i can get this off real quick no
there's been a couple super chats oh i
saw con artists who was before caught on
us
oh no you you read the yeah i got the
other one yeah so this is con artist
shout out to conor's 10 hours super chat
he said one my wife likes the halo show
too and two
can phil be on the show please shout out
to paris
hey we love that fella to show you
already know what you talking about on
our show i thought you were talking
about it on paramount show i'm like you
wanna fill up the halo series i said
what you want him to be
you know you know what they should do
make phil spencer one of the other
spartans
no anyway you know i will i would love
for him to feel
that would be hilarious oh oh okay
forte's here if i was with chad king we
can't blame everything on the pandemic
343 been missing that source for years i
need the core experience to be better
and also
hey king hey to be honest with you
because you wanted you wanted destiny to
be better for years and i didn't see the
same type of energy coming out from you
then
uh second off the core experience is
good on on on on halo it's everything
else that needs to happen
okay you you okay
you're not going to go at me and then
you know hit me with the sugar coat
[Laughter]
you're not going to go out you didn't
get the hey okay
i got it
so i'm i'm going to say this
the game is dope i'm blaming it on the
pandemic because a lot of games [ __ ]
broken a lot of games ship messed up a
lot of games got pushed back so we're
not gonna act like something didn't
happen when it did happen we're not
living in a normal time so
i can't go back and fix it i'm sorry you
wanted co-op you didn't get it i'm sorry
you want forge you don't get it but
maybe in the next dlc right after this
lone wolf you will get it and you will
be happy you'll be right back bending
the knee talking about how fantastic it
is but c you'll still be here and we
will still participate together see you
in six months thank you enough shot out
to
mommy oh split difference so we took out
some chats so we not gonna talk about
showing cheeks and halo
i know what he's referencing
look after the whole season's over oh
you haven't seen he's gonna do it
episode three yeah yeah you need to
we're gonna do a spoiler cast that you
guys you this all i'm saying is the
third episode you're going to want me to
be there you're going to want to be in
the building when that spoiler cast
happens but today ain't that day guys
no doubt salute you already know i do
have before we move on to the last topic
i do have to take care of some business
on the merge side shout out to anonymous
please say something we bought a beanie
a while back got the ilp beating salute
shout out to someone that got the face
mask get the protection on salute
backpack anonymous gotta say your name
leave a comment let me see you gotta put
your twitter handle yeah
now here's the thing though these are
this one was a couple days before shout
out to anonymous again who brought the
pax east so this person's gonna come to
pax to see us all right lord roughness
today this is the first one addict we
got lord roughness he got the um he got
the old the horseman joint the classic
horseman t he said this is lord love
russell's picking up some merch lord
roughness dm me we will get you that
also that forty dollar gift card exactly
forty dollars
keep in mind too here in the next
probably three to four months we're
gonna like we're gonna uh we're having
custom like yep merchandise yeah for you
guys so you guys are gonna like that
and and we want that show me your build
yeah we want to make that next emoji for
you i want y'all to hit how to get
through
you start making more stuff i want y'all
to attack addict on this show me your
bill because i think show me your build
is funny as hell could y'all please
put your name give your twitter handle
so you could get
something extra
give me that premium powder baby there's
four left because the other dude won't
qualify because yes four it's four left
it's four left so right now just lower
roughness and that's it so make sure you
get some merch the links at the top or
description go get you some iop merch
get your little you know whatever then
get yourself a little foil i wish
somebody would have gave me forty
dollars awesome exactly shout out to
forte financial chat
hold up don't make me pull up
i've been killing bungie for years with
the direction of the game don't come for
me homie you know how i roll okay forte
i don't see the same energy towards
bungie that you have three four three
though i don't even see relatively the
same
sling difference what about that powder
god don't act like i didn't hit you no
you did i'm talking about for the people
for the merch just the new giveaway
we're doing today and it's iron lord 20
on the merc so oh yeah people probably
don't know like that's the beginning of
the show right now if you buy there it's
tagged in the the little blue icon
if you buy any of our merchant no i
think it's the packed shirt yeah you
will get a 40 gift code to the advanced
uh gg thing all right and it's for the
the the powder stuff it's not for
anything else just for the powder stuff
moving on anyway finally the description
is
so
king's topic man unreal engine 5
cavern
demo the coalition
king this is you man you want to talk
about it man
well you know unreal
uh had a state of unreal
uh a couple of days ago and it's been
going on for like so far like a week or
whatever and i'm i've been getting a lot
of insight on going in and the fact that
um they were in collaborations with the
coalition um remember the coalition and
epic uh
started off together basically and you
know they branched off and did a lot of
the gears games
and they focal point has really been the
unreal engine
uh and
they're lending hands and working in
collaboration with epic in the unreal
engine uh five i saw the demo
of
of that that demo and
not to say it was probably the least
impressive from all the other demos that
were there but this is actual
which looks like game application
if if if i can say that because a lot of
other ones were movie applications anime
applications uh
you know different different things
because unreal is actually that
versatile where you can use it in
different applications but this one
actually looks like a game that they're
working on or could be working on and
swapping out uh different uh facial
features and everything
it looked incredible
this is the cinematic experiences that
we've been asking for from microsoft and
i think the coalition will be one of the
first uh
developers in the stable of microsoft uh
large vast 36 stable
developers that they do have now and i
think the coalition is poised to bring
that uh naughty dog type of um
next cinematics to it what did y'all
think about when you saw the state of uh
unreal and what did y'all think about
when you saw this cavern actual demo
from the coalition lord lockheed perez
what do you feel man you e5 that cavern
demo what was your thoughts on it
um i haven't even checked it out yet
there's something i'm missing i'm
missing i'll get you that link brothers
yeah give me the thing because i've been
uh i've been
i was actually searching
i got you i got you yeah i was listening
i was like oh man but you know um i
think that there's the opportunities
that they're going to be providing just
the engines alone i don't know if uh
unreal five it's just it's gonna be
incredible they got that new 3d model
and stuff like that that they're
releasing so
um i am
i'm excited to see
what the game developers are going to be
able to do
i'm just saying hashtag metaverse and
we're gonna
see what happens
though i just said the link while i let
addict talk about it um
yeah man um
chucky d i'm lucky oh so yeah so lord
attic man did you get a chance to check
out the caverns uh test demo on unreal
engine 5 coalition i saw a good amount
of it like it's impressive but
a lot of it just goes to like what the
what the textures look like how nice it
looks on the screen and that's nice and
there's people like king that like that
stuff and i like it to a point but like
i'm more about i want to push
features ahead that's why i always talk
about the nemesis like i want more
features and more gameplay mechanics
like like nemesis engine that's pushing
ai ahead that's pushing you know
gameplay behaviors ahead and you know
hopefully because what
looks like to me is
this game uh this engine is going to
make a lot of the the
you know the the little stuff easier for
them to do right so maybe they can focus
more on the big stuff you know changing
ai behavior and stuff i've always said
that's why you know when it comes to
something like the nemesis engine uh i
always just like the the ai i want the
ais to yeah
that's the biggest thing i want the ais
to approve and another thing i don't see
a lot of people talking about when it
comes to uh you know unreal improving is
it's going to force unity to improve
it's going to force snow bite to improve
like it's got they're going to have to
compete engines and they're going to amp
up their game too and before you know it
next five years we're going to have
drastically different games both in
looking how it plays because
one ups their game forcing the rest to
do it yeah i think this will help you
uh get what you're looking for because
um from what i've seen and what i
understand and grasp from it
is it alleviates a lot of the cpu heavy
uh lifting
with the the nanites um um
and the lumen engine chanted takes away
from the the calculation process of it
and it frees up that underhead and the
overhead for actual ai use that you're
talking about to make the game smarter
to make the enemies are more dynamic to
make
more life like in the actual worlds that
you're creating uh
the the way the volumetric fog is used
now and you can see that aspect of it in
that cavern demo uh it changes uh how
things can actually be perceived because
the level of fog distance and everything
and it can actually you know hide you uh
give a different level of awareness for
your characters so i think you're going
to get exactly what you're looking for
when it comes to the unreal engine and
pushing everybody else forward i think
so yeah i mean look you know i'll jump
in you know it's definitely impressive
we i want to shout out the coalition
because we don't think we we really give
them their flowers from a graphical
fidelity standpoint of kind of holding
xbox down i mean even a lot of people
look at them to show what unreal yeah i
mean they even helped out on that matrix
demo from my understanding the uh the
music when it came out and the thing
that's impressive to me like
it's
it's more of like okay
we we see
what they can do you see the potential
of the engine like i know addicts
talking about the ai you're talking
about that stuff but i looked at what
they did with like unreal engine four
and i remember you know
hot buses don't get enough credit for
like like how from i think that was the
pinnacle get like when i i was like okay
i think a lot of people who are not on
board with the xbox ecosystem yet
the the the complaint or the feedback is
we want to see that power we want to see
stuff where the series x is outside and
you know what i'm saying what is the
king all natural graphical situations
you know i'm saying they want to see
that
right that i think it's important and
that's why i again coalition has been
doing it so long i don't want to
disrespect any man turn turns another
one you know a lot of them doing it but
like let's be honest a lot about money's
on turn 10 right a lot of people do want
something obviously outside of a cargo
horizon looks beautiful we get it
playground we get it everything's
beautiful but we from uh from those type
of experiences right the just ones or
whatever you know
coalition's really been in that bag so
to see them kind of show out like this
the potential is really impressive and
um um do you think it's because it's not
an exclusive title just to the series
consoles
um that they don't get that whole i
think ignition my my honest answer is
it's what i said before it's unfair
but i think it's what we talked about
the the the big mac large fraud shake
halo gears forza these titles are
amazing let's not be disrespectful these
titles are amazing they push things
forward and especially together can
easily
easily carry a whole platform literally
so what it is is sometimes that's like
when they take it for granted phase oh
yeah but what else you know what i said
but what else can you do you know kind
of and i think what's cool is juggling
right right yeah so i think
maybe from the outside not the inside
because everybody recognizes gear is
amazing and stuff like that but like for
the outside maybe if they had like that
one warm-up title
before potentially a gear six or
something like that you're talking about
something separate departure maybe
anything like gorilla games did
maybe maybe that's what it takes for
other people to truly give them their
flowers that i feel they deserve you
know saying because when i look at gears
right and i again i tell people i
remember when series x was like yo
nothing really showing off the system
and i'm like bro did you download high
buzzers
like did you do the dlc
exactly
when it's completely it's really a step
up from the actual gears of gear five oh
yeah it's a complete step up when you
actually do it but okay so
so you're in the camp that you want
coalition
to take a break from gears for a second
and to to probably expand their horizon
in something else i mean i walked in the
finished game
here's my thing i'm not gonna if gear
six is on the table you know so b
you know i do think with a new engine
again i'm not a dev but my you know my
new thing is just a new engine there's
you know probably a learning curve and
getting won't getting acclimated they
did explain that right so so you know
let's put it this way if it's a new
title great if it's
the marcus phoenix collection
[Music]
i do got to say i agree with you king
i'm tired of the collection of your
collections there but i do understand if
coalition wants to have a smaller title
to get to use to the unreal engine 5 to
really know how to own its skills oh
if it
the marcus phoenix collection that
they're using to learn how to use yeah
the unreal engine five oh i'm okay yeah
i just watched the warm-up so you gave
me my praise but then smack me
i just want a warm-up title that's all
that's something that's something that i
do
i'm not a fan of it look let me let me
ask a little paris like you know i
obviously can't talk but in a perfect
world
what would you like
for the coalition
in a perfect world i mean
why limit a studio to just one title oh
thank you that went over people here
okay
let's see what you're saying i see what
you mean i see what you mean man like
yeah like look at you acting like this
isn't what everyone thinks it's called
i'm just no but i mean we gotta ask him
for his perspective of it and and the
fact that he's he he has to be able to
move around the conversation in the
sense that you know uh he could have
privileged the knowledge that we don't
know yeah
you know
obsidian has multiple titles you know um
there's studios you know certain sizes
that have multiple projects going on
[Music]
this unreal because i didn't know this
was a thing somebody had uh text me and
it was like are you ready for tomorrow
for the unreal uh the state of state of
unreal yeah and i thought he was being
funny i thought he was poking fun at
playstation playstation i don't have no
state of play tomorrow speaking right
but then it was it was a state of unreal
so i tuned in and i watched it and they
talked about the misconception that
people think that you can just click a
button right going from unreal four to
unreal five and if that's not it right
um a lot of the things in the procedures
is absolutely different right and what
they did explain was they have different
revisions of you know updates to the
engine
like four point one two four point uh
two seven and stuff like that and where
they're at now what they did explain was
if you're gonna upgrade from and they'll
talk you through it if it uh makes any
sense for you to upgrade your project
from unreal engine 4 to unreal engine 5.
but if you are going to upgrade you're
not going to go to each version of it
you're going to go to the highest
version of it to maximize it gotcha and
a lot of the features promised features
are turned off at the moment they just
turned off just turned on the nano
um for those individuals that are
actually using the engine right demo is
up for a lot of you early developers
that are out there that want to get a
chance to do it people making a superman
game with that matrix engine that's what
i wanted to talk to you about yeah i see
like i got to send you the link on that
one it it
yeah oh it looked amazing like it gave
you protect you like
yo you don't say like it could be done
and he's flying around this you know
this this intricate kind of city in that
demo so it was it was impressive i was
going to ask
again it was more impressive
knowing that the coalition yes worked
with
epic on that matrix demo the matrix demo
that everybody was shouting from the top
of the mountaintops talking about it was
the next greatest thing the most
photorealistic uh
cinematic
demo that they can ever play
the coalition the makers of gears well
yeah the
the the purveyors of gears at the moment
right now
did that for you
who did that for you
i see what you're doing like i liked
what i saw on that thing but like once
again like i want to see more gameplay
innovation so like at this point like
graphics aren't wowing me anymore like
at all whatsoever what i think you might
appreciate from that demo if you try it
yet is the um
the ai from like a city standpoint the
way things
interact and stuff like this there's a
couple of things that they highlight but
we'll get into it i wanted to ask real
quick um lolacki did you get a chance to
see that thing real quick the uh yeah
yeah i saw the video yeah
it's clear yeah it's clear and
concise now let's read some of the the
rendering uh on the unreal website one
thing that people
i think when people go visit the the
unreal website when they talk about the
release notes and stuff like that you'll
see that it they're given the ability
for smaller
games to build
games right so
all the sort of indie titles that were
you know they sort of
the graphics aren't there but they got
incredible stories
the graphics aren't there because they
just don't have the yeah bandwidth and
the the people power to be able to
generate something like that yeah now if
they have the opportunity one row five
to do something that
puts them in a different category and
allows them to expand on their graphics
and stuff
that's huge that's huge yeah i'm glad
you said that because
for me like again no disrespect to the
indie scene it's like you know like you
said whether it be the resources the
budget or what have you to get these
licenses for these engine or whatever if
there's if the barrier the entry is
lower or they're making it easier you
know kind of similar to what you guys
are doing with id at azure right where
you're giving indie developers that
ability to say look you get these
credits you can have this backbone on
the same level almost you know as a
triple a title a bigger bigger studio
now we may see potential of indies with
this type of you know little graphical
fidelity or like that's that's really
exciting that's really exciting yeah
yeah
and that's what sort of pops you'd be
like whoa this is any title
e5 no absolutely and the last thing i'll
say you know child we had the great um
lord bill stillwell on back when the ue5
demo first happened king remember when
it was on playstation there's there was
talk at the time it was exclusive
the uu a5 was locked it whole engine it
was and you know bill it was feisty he
was like look it's a multi-platform
engine and he got a lot of flack for it
but uh you know it goes short obviously
the engine is clearly you know not
exclusive
versatile yeah especially when coalition
helps it
you're ridiculous but you know it it
goes to show you you know i just like to
see that cinematic
high level graphical fidelity engines
and i'm excited when more studios get a
hold of this thing and what type of
games that we can see so yeah man see
what's going on that's all i got on that
let's wrap up get up out of here it's
definitely a fantastic show oh fantastic
yeah the only thing i was gonna say at
the end of that yeah
it gives the opportunity to give gamers
what we want like we want good games and
we want to play and
opening it up gives other people
opportunities to create you know it's
not close to just the big studios
anymore right so yep
i think number goodness from it so i
think it gives us fans and us people
that work at companies like this the
ability to see the
the fruits and the work and all that
stuff that they put into creating great
games for people absolutely especially
when you can use your xbox and turn it
into a development system and you can
use id at xbox to your advantage and you
could be part of hopefully game pass in
the future and you can use xcloud so wow
wow all right
real quick real quick before we uh wrap
up uh they this tier thing is because i
saw some people in the chat want to talk
about it real quick it's not too much to
talk about apparently like a
like a like a table was leaked i don't
know if it's true or not you guys know
how it is but yeah uh the family plan uh
looks like it might be 25 a month for
two to five people
and it's pretty much everything on
ultimate just for 25 a month and you'll
have up to two to five people you think
that would be a pretty uh successful
price i think that's a good price like
listen two to five people for all i'll
tell you right now if the rumors are
true
we got a lot of new family members
you're gonna have in your family
that's gonna won't be down with your
program you're gonna get a lot of new
cousins another brother's popping up
talking about your attic what's up bro
but i do feel like that cause that's the
only thing i was worried about like if
that is the price and it first off it's
not been announced but okay the second
office regulation and that is the price
i think that's a solid price that would
actually have a lot of uh a lot of go
with it what do you think king i think
it i think it works well
um because right now game sharing with
my son so our game pass and stuff like
that it's like but um in order to get my
daughters involved i will have to have
the family plan yeah so in doing so i
actually saved money
with you because 15 you know me and my
son but if i can do up to five people
for 25
i can definitely do that add my
daughters on to the plan you know um and
they'll play xcloud on the go on their
phone
so small i love it there's
professionalism
he's just looking at us like i'm just
saying the fact that
i'm
look i think it's
it's it's a feather in the cap i mean um
if the rumors are true and the price
point is true you know we all we're all
going to get it together we just go
who eat them now but you know you know
for a fact like
during the xbox one era i remember
seeing a lot of stuff baked in the back
end already you know and you can kind of
put in family and i remember i had
mark's move as a family member or this
person yeah you know and obviously the
drm got to take down at the time but
microsoft was already ahead of this in
my opinion so it's just a matter of now
implementing it coming up with a
structure my only curiosity is from um
metrics standpoint how would it be
measured from a live user do they count
like if you have a five ma yeah bad
family playing like is that five count
as five people towards that scene yeah
you know they're about to get that
engagement that engagement is going to
be crazy
but this is where the numbers grow all
right um because if you're part of the
family plan you have the five people
there right then that's five people
right right and less likely to
unsubscribe yeah that's one
one one person i mean one subscriber
but that's actual five engagements so
they're gonna count that actual five so
it's one person one purchase will equal
five yes this is where you're gonna have
an outcry from a lot of individuals that
like to count numbers
[Laughter]
the numbers dudes is going to be ups but
there's only one notes five
because it's five of us because yeah i
don't know how it works on the back one
hand five people
i know what you do i know what you're
doing i know what this fits right into
your numbers narrative with gamepad i
know what you did here yeah 75 million
because you get 25
it's really fun
i know somebody in the meeting said hey
man i put my one hand up but i got five
fingers we're gonna include five people
uh here we go here we go we're gonna use
you you're funny yeah but look if if if
the rumors are true shout out there oh i
believe jess gordon was one of the first
widow central you know to break this
rumor we'll see what happens and now
announce and then you know lord power is
going to talk about it officially when
anything does happen we'll talk in an
official context but um look let's get
these super chats let's get invited here
oh let's let's let paris go so we can
read the super chat oh before i'm sorry
before
with the latest gdc tech demo of ue5
which xbox game studio project has you
most excited in terms of graphical
fidelity the choices are heavy hitter
hellblade 2
b
rumored out of worlds 2
c
red fall supposed to be ue5 and this
year or d i don't care y'all already
know whatever project the coalition is
doing they are the lords of ue5 so
better
so make sure you go hit that poll up the
choices and all that rock the vote again
salute to the legendary lord paris
lockhart rock throughout the entire
episode
iron man float that was iron man flow
right there a legend in the game brother
we are very honored to have you that you
took the time that you trusted us on on
our platform to come here celebrate your
journey we're very impressed with what
you're doing you know game streaming the
xbox team salute to you guys it's just
it's wonderful to have that level of
transparency with executives and i know
it takes a lot to take out of your day
so we truly want to salute you and
appreciate you tell the fine people
where they can find you and what you
have going on sir
yeah you can find me on uh twitter
p-lock77
um you can find me on xbox
uh
gamer tag locky charms oh that's charms
with the mz yeah yeah um and you can
find me um i also do some co-hosting
with the with 4gq tv
marvel shows and stuff like that so we
are talking about marvel and then you
can get you a king i gotta do a statue
or something yeah you guys should jump
on that and we can jump on that anytime
you guys want to have some conversation
about marvel if you guys want absolutely
we have something fun with it um
uh you know carl and them do a great job
um and then um uh the marvel cinematic
facebook yeah join that have some fun
talk to everything all the things marvel
and of course play some xbox
like some yeah streaming yes next
[Laughter]
y'all come at me and i'll be knowing the
truth
i told you ninety-seven percent man come
on stop playing with me you were digging
down to your brother tried to boot up uh
socom the other day i got here oh right
because yo here we go
[Music]
yeah i appreciate you coming on lock uh
we've had a couple xbox live parties
they're always a lively person to be
around
uh you know it what i like about being
in parties with you guys
is i hear enough of the twitter stuff
going on
this that going on so like i've noticed
like being a part of you guys like let's
keep the game being like social aspect
of it let's just play games and
sometimes i like that yeah and i don't
get that a lot it likes
i'll be jumping a party if there's
someone else jumps up or like added what
do you think about this i'm like i
probably have a video go watch it like
you don't need to put a game the game as
opposed to the news every five minutes
i'll see you all right i'll feel you no
doubt lord king i was gonna see the lord
paris lockhart before he heads up he's
so be worthy
nice nice nice i love that where did you
get that from uh uh it's a prop replica
of the first millionaire
um i got it from forbidden planets in
new york city okay and that's awesome
high quality comic book store this is
this is crazy it's really heavy it's a
blunt object
oh you get locked up now you can
actually throw it if somebody come in
like thor
yo it's crazy
it's crazy if if it could come back i'll
rule the world
but um i knew he was coming on so i
definitely had to bring that out i was
gonna bring my captain america shell but
i left it on the wall
huge marvel fan uh anticipated uh
showing up today uh dory's gonna talk a
little bit more about it but i
understand that'll be a 12-hour show
can't do that
but also love your journey i love that
whole the japanese story oh the street
fighter story was fire brother
that that's that was that was it right
there and then the fact that you know
you educated me on alaska where i was
absolutely ignorant
because i'm pretty sure the last season
of dexter was there
i'm done with you he's ridiculous
but
you know um so you brought up my
horizons today and i do appreciate that
and i and i loved i love the man cave i
love your energy i love your whole
history you know tecmo bowl and
everything and thank you for coming on
giving us your dates you know sunday is
probably a rest day and you actually you
rocked out the whole whole show bro i
don't think we had did we no john we
gotta give jason ronaldo he's probably
jason jason ryan rocked out right the
whole show yeah jason yeah that's my guy
man yeah so you out here this this is
what it is and i do appreciate your time
fantastic now everybody in the universe
is going to hit you up talking about
please be on my show
[Laughter]
but uh you're welcome as a lord here all
the time i can't wait to
you know all meet together and stuff
like that it'd be awesome absolutely
yeah it's been great you guys do a
wonderful job i've seen some other
microsoft uh xbox heads been on the been
on the show so it's been great um you
guys do a wonderful job do a lot for the
community of gaming
it's all positive
um and that's that's what it's all about
i love uh the content that you guys are
able to produce and um
and and and you know you don't dive into
the negative stuff you like you keep it
for what it is it's negative and then
you just
you go through it and then you just
leave it alone right so this is great it
means a lot the issue the issue people
have when it comes to that it's like oh
when they hear is that all you guys you
guys just aren't talking about
everything you choose no we talk about
it but here we don't have every podcast
dedicated to it we talk about it we give
our constructed criticism we move the
hell along oh yeah that's what it is you
know what i'm saying now for real i
appreciate that a lot it means a lot you
know to hear that because you know for
us you know getting the respect from
your peers but also you know again you
guys let's be honest you guys are gaming
heroes in the sense that you guys create
the experiences that we play and we
enjoy daily you know i mean and it's
only right i feel on this platform to
give people their flowers there's a lot
of negativity out there there's a lot of
armchair developers out there
all they got to do and there's a lot of
financial analysts and let's get the
people on who are actually doing the
work
get it directly from the source
i low key like the armchair developers
because they're so easy to kill on a
debate no it's great when they're wrong
and then i could just bring up the
receipts
yeah exactly because i mean we talked
about so many other topics on the show
we're like oh yeah that was disproven
right
it's fun you know it's it's cool to have
again these type of conversations so i
appreciate you brother really cool and
thank you so much we got to give you
your flowers on that as well um just two
superchats actually we actually do
better we get about it yeah um yeah
superstar seek of the great ten dollar
superchat shout out to my bros iop and
cog i'm still waiting to see that marvel
movie you landed in fayette i ain't got
no deal you got a hot lock for that i
don't know about the movie oven but um
shout out to split difference still have
a chat what if treyarch makes the next
halo what do you think hmm
i don't know about that no no see i
don't know about that
eyeballs and i'm gonna say i like the
direction that three four three is in
leave us alone
dragon says any scene no doubt forte
what do you think it'd be upgrade path
if the pricing structure is true yeah
they might be forte again it's going to
pass ultimately for the next two years
where i'll be the upgrade to the family
service for cheaper i guess so we're
gonna see
that's it when are we gonna get sarah
ball now they wanna feel they once said
lock they want everybody just be happy
what is the twitter oh what is the
twitter for locker it is in the um iron
laws podcast on trey keep calling him
lockhart that's his last name
but oh yeah so there's also there's
[Music]
my daughter's name is scarlet i'm just
gonna leave that alone
yo phil you're funny phil i see what you
doing boy the next man there's no
relationship the next child
that
so we gotta look to you we gotta look to
you we gotta
it was in the meeting room and he was
talking he was talking and he just
brought up his oh that is it right
names and the roadmap to xbox has been
hiding in plain sight this whole time oh
my god
we broke the code we broke the call
y'all we did it man the conspiracy
theories are gonna stop
oh my god
[Laughter]
oh shout out to
anonymous oh you got to put your name
you bought a pax and you bought a shirt
you didn't he did comment in the chat
that said it wouldn't let him all right
just like here's the thing okay
we could give you that
but there's a chance that you just saw
that pop up on the screen we gotta do it
officially yeah sorry man
as much as i would like to take your
word
listen
you follow us online right yeah yeah
just screenshot the shape
and then dm me to us
cognito on twitter dmv a good way of
doing it
so that's all i got anybody got anything
else for we roll out of here
uh no uh you know definitely pull up to
the attic show uh i haven't confirmed
our gas so i'm not going to say the gas
yeah ty got travis this week that was
dope
yeah uh it will be wednesday at 5 00 p.m
i appreciate everyone coming through we
had about almost 600 people in the
church yes thank you definitely i like
button we have 390 videos
we'll see you next week we we are uh you
know we we're looking into something for
pax for you guys so we'll get to you
guys later on that but i appreciate ever
coming through and we'll see you next
week no doubt king anything else you
good yeah it's friday i mean well well
friday darth castle x jcx it's going to
be crazy it's going to be off the charts
what is dc actually educate urge
okay well that's uh the statue uh show
that i do uh for us uh thousands and a
couple of millionaires that actually
collect these uh high performance
statues uh not toys because uh we have a
lot of dudes that would like to send me
marvel legends and no
um the premium premium statue talk yeah
that's the marvel cinematic universe and
dc yeah yeah okay king king talk to
megan tell him to get his break his
stuff out he needs to get his stuff
together i've been trying to tell him
let's get megatron listen i taught i
tried to get him to pick up i have a
megatron and um optimus prime always
fire and i
prime one i i try to give him a great
deal but he has little children he
doesn't trust them around
[Music]
[Laughter]
uh we have combat talk with the king
coming back this weekend
well next weekend uh with errol spence
versus
that's the fight that's coming back uh
just sit around with me if you don't
have anybody to watch the fight with i
guarantee at some point in that night i
will make you pee on yourself
we will have fun we will laugh we will
talk about it you're not gonna see the
fight so hopefully you watching the
fight in your house i'm watching the
fight in my house and we're talking
about the fight going on and you have a
buddy to talk to
watching the fight just come hang out a
couple of hundred friends of us yes
talking about the fight no doubt and you
already know spend difference cog that
powder yes again last and not least i go
to the website go to iron lord podcast
go to lordsgaming.net go to the team
shop go check it out go pick up the pack
stuff go pick up some merch again if you
get that merch and also go to
advancedgg.com
you can use iron lord 20 get the 20 off
but if you get the merch you get that 40
gift card go check that out that's all i
got everybody enjoy your sunday thank
you for rocking out it's a lot of fun
everybody peace
xcloud
so
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
wow
[Music]